Thank you for listening to The Rest is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. I see another child tonight. He hears the train go by at night, and he dreams of faraway places where he'd like to go. It seems like an impossible dream, but he is helped on his journey through life. A father who had to go to work before he finished the sixth grade sacrificed everything he had so that his sons could go to college. A gentle Quaker mother with a passionate concern for peace, quietly wept when he went to war, but she understood
感谢收听《历史的 Rest is History》。想要获取每周的独家加更节目、无广告收听体验、系列节目的抢先收听资格以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区的会员资格，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。今晚我又看到另一个孩子。他听着火车在夜里驶过，梦想着他想去的遥远地方。这似乎是一个不可能的梦想，但在他的人生旅程中，他得到了帮助。一个在小学六年级还没读完就不得不去工作的父亲牺牲了他拥有的一切，好让他的儿子们能上大学。一位对和平怀有热切关怀的温柔的贵格会母亲，在他参军时默默流泪，但她理解
why he had to go. A great teacher, a remarkable football coach, an inspirational minister encouraged him on his way. A courageous wife and loyal children stood by him in victory and also in defeat. And in his chosen profession of politics, first there were scores, then hundreds, then thousands, and finally millions worked for his success, and tonight he stands before you, nominated for President of the United States of America. The unmistakable tones one might say Dominic of Richard Milhouse Nixon, your great hero,
他为什么非去不可。一位伟大的老师、一位卓越的足球教练、一位鼓舞人心的牧师在路上鼓励了他。一位勇敢的妻子和忠诚的孩子在胜利和失败中都坚定地支持他。在他选择的政治生涯中，先是几十人，然后是数百人，接着是数千人，最后是数百万人为他的成功而努力，今晚他站在你们面前，被提名竞选美利坚合众国总统。可以说是具有理查德·米尔豪斯·尼克森标志性语调的——你的伟大英雄——
accepting the Republican presidential nomination of Miami Beach on the 8th of August, 1968. Well. And how do you think I did with that? I think you did well actually. You did very well. I don't think Nixon broke down at all while doing that speech. No. So it's an impressionist impression. Yes, it is.
于1968年8月8日在迈阿密海滩接受共和党总统提名。好。你觉得我这段模仿得怎么样？我觉得你模仿得挺好的，真的。你模仿得非常好。我觉得尼克逊在做那次演讲时一点也没有情绪崩溃。没有。所以这是一种印象派的模仿。是的，没错。
I'm evoking the sense of the maudlin, the self-pity, the melodrama inherent within Nixon's oratory. You captured the inner man. That's what I was trying to do, yes. So that is textbook Nixon, isn't it? Because some people listen to that may consider that excruciatingly manipulative. Yeah, some might. Indeed nauseating, but other people might think it brilliant. Absolutely brilliant. Brilliantly crafted. He kept out checkers, his dog this time, didn't he? He didn't mention checkers. And the thing is there were always more of the latter,
我在唤起尼克逊演讲中所特有的那种多愁善感、自怜和情节剧般的戏剧色彩。你抓住了他内心的本质。这正是我试图做到的，是的。所以这是典型的尼克逊风格，不是吗？因为有些人听到这段可能会觉得极其具有操纵性。是的，有些人可能会这么觉得。甚至可以说是令人作呕，但其他人可能会觉得这太精彩了。绝对精彩。构思精妙。他这次把他的狗“奇克斯”藏起来了，对吧？他没有提到奇克斯。问题在于，后者总是比前者更多，
the people who thought it was brilliant than the people who thought it was nauseating. And that is why Richard Nixon was one of American history's great winners. You know, he doesn't just win the presidency once, he wins it twice. And we've gone all through this story of 68 without really talking about Nixon. And the funny thing about the 68 story is that he is often a little bit overlooked because he is the big winner after all the chaos and the excitement of the year, the things that draw most people's attention, the assassinations, the Yippies, the Vietnam War, all that kind of business.
觉得它精彩的人比觉得它令人作呕的人更多。这就是为什么理查德·尼克逊是美国历史上的伟大赢家之一。你知道，他不仅仅是赢得了一次总统大选，他赢得了两次。我们在没有真正谈到尼克逊的情况下，把68年的整个故事讲完了。68年故事有趣的地方在于，他经常被稍微忽视，因为在经历了这一年的所有混乱和兴奋、吸引了最多人注意的事情（比如暗杀、嬉皮士、越战以及所有这类事情）之后，他毕竟是那个大赢家。
Because his campaign is very deliberately boring, isn't it? Yes. And actually that becomes a slight problem towards the actual date of the election, but that's his goal, isn't it? But his campaign works, right? In the long run, yeah. The champion of middle America, he pulls off one of the great comebacks in American history, but not an uncontroversial victory. So we will come to that, to the conspiracy theories that surround it.
因为他的竞选非常刻意地表现得很无聊，不是吗？是的。而且实际上，随着大选日期的临近，这成了一个小问题，但这正是他的目标，不是吗？但他的竞选奏效了，对吧？从长远来看，是的。作为美国中产阶级的捍卫者，他上演了美国历史上最伟大的卷土重来之一，但这并非一场没有争议的胜利。所以我们稍后会讲到这一点，以及围绕它的阴谋论。
But perhaps we should start, Tom. We did episodes on Watergate back in the very early days of the rest of history. But for those people who didn't listen to those, remind ourselves about Richard M. Nixon. I noticed you called him, you said he was my hero. I wouldn't quite say he was my hero. No, I was being ironic. I do have a tendresse for Richard Nixon. I find him endlessly entertaining and fascinating. Nixon, as he would be the first to tell you, came from a very poor family in Yorba Linda, California in 1913, Quaker family. And he's a genuine meritocrat. I mean, he really does pull himself up by his bootstraps.
但也许我们应该从头开始，汤姆。我们在《历史的 Rest is History》极早期的时候就做过关于水门事件的节目。但对于那些没有听过这些节目的人，让我们来回顾一下理查德·M·尼克逊。我注意到你称呼他时，说他是我的英雄。我不能完全说他是我的英雄。不，我刚才是在开玩笑。我对理查德·尼克逊确实有点偏爱。我发现他有着无穷的娱乐性和迷人之处。正如尼克逊自己最乐意告诉你的一样，他于1913年出生于加利福尼亚州约巴林达的一个非常贫困的家庭，这是一个贵格会家庭。他是一个真正的精英主义者。我的意思是，他真的是靠自己的努力白手起家。
He goes to Duke Law School. He's in the Navy in the war. He goes to Congress. And he can't go to Harvard, can he? Because he can't afford the fees or something. Right, exactly. He can't go to the East Coast. At least that's what he says.
他去读了杜克大学法学院。他在战争期间加入海军。他进入了国会。他不能去哈佛，对吧？因为他付不起学费什么的。没错，正是如此。他去不了东海岸。至少他是这么说的。
And of course he wears that very heavily. And he always talks about the East Coast Ivy League people who look down on me because I only went to Whittier College and Duke Law School, all this stuff. He made his name in Congress as an anti-communist, very aggressive, very partisan, got into the Senate. The Democrats hated him. They always thought he was underhand, far too pugnacious, far too belligerent. A nasty man, I think, is what they thought. He became Eisenhower's vice president. You mentioned Checkers the dog.
当然，他对此非常耿耿于怀。他总是谈论那些东海岸常春藤盟校的人，他们看不起我，因为我只上过惠蒂尔学院和杜克法学院，诸如此类的话。他在国会崭露头角时是一个反共主义者，非常激进、非常具有党派色彩，后来进入了参议院。民主党人恨透了他。他们总觉得他为人卑劣、好斗过头、好战过头。我想他们觉得他是个令人讨厌的人。他成了艾森豪威尔的副总统。你提到了那条叫奇克斯的狗。
That's how he got public attention by doing this TV broadcast in which he taught the girls love the dog and they're going to keep him because he'd been given by a donor. Yes, exactly. Then he lost the 1960 election to Kennedy. I remember when we did our Kennedy series, we talked about the Nixon-Kennedy debates and how unbelievably impressive they are by modern day standards. They're so articulate, serious, thoughtful, well-informed. And actually Nixon and Kennedy got on all right. I mean, there were stories of them
这就是他通过电视广播引起公众注意的方式，他在广播中说女儿们很喜欢这条狗，而且她们打算留着它，因为这是捐赠者送的。是的，完全是这样。后来他在1960年的大选中输给了肯尼迪。我记得当我们做肯尼迪系列节目时，我们讨论了尼克逊与肯尼迪的辩论，以现代标准来看，他们是多么令人难以置信地印象深刻。他们表达得如此清晰、严肃、深思熟虑、见多识广。实际上尼克逊和肯尼迪相处得还不错。我的意思是，有报道说他们
going back to Washington from debates in the train. Yeah, on the train when they were young men. Doing the fat and things. Exactly. Nixon is a smart guy. And actually, if you're not fighting a campaign against him, he's not terrible company. You know, he's very well read. He's serious. He's self-improving all of this. So, you know, he's in a different league from a lot of his successors, I think it's fair to say. Then having lost in 1960, he lost the race for governor of California, his home state in 1962. And then he snapped and he showed the ugly face of Nixon. So he snapped at the press after losing. Just think how much you're going to be missing.
从辩论地点坐火车回华盛顿。是的，他们在年轻时坐火车。吃零食之类的。没错。尼克逊是个聪明人。而且事实上，如果你不是在同他进行竞选对抗，他其实算不上糟糕的同伴。你知道，他博览群书。他很严肃。他不断自我完善，诸如此类。所以，你知道，与他的许多继任者相比，他完全不在一个量级上，我认为这样说很公平。接着，在1960年落败后，他又在1962年输掉了他家乡加利福尼亚州的州长竞选。然后他崩溃了，露出了尼克逊丑陋的一面。所以在落选后，他对记者发了脾气。想想你们会有多怀念他吧。
You don't have Nixon to kick around anymore because gentlemen, this is my last press conference. This kind of the real bit in the stem. And self pity one might say. And self pity. And the papers printed his obituary and they basically said, he's done, he's out. That's the end of Richard Nixon in politics. So Nixon then went off to New York and he became a Wall Street lawyer. He lived on Fifth Avenue. His daughters were debutantes.
你们再也没有尼克逊可以欺负了，因为先生们，这是我的最后一次记者招待会。这可以说是压垮骆驼的最后一根稻草。可以说是一种自怜。而且充满了自怜。各大报纸刊登了他的讣告，他们基本上说，他完了，他出局了。理查德·尼克逊的政治生涯到此结束。于是尼克逊随后前往纽约，成了一名华尔街律师。他住在第五大道。他的女儿们都是社交名媛。
I mean, they genuinely had debutante balls in Manhattan in those days. Maybe still do, I don't know. He hangs around in country clubs with country club Republicans. He works for Pepsi. He's a sort of corporate ambassador. So he goes off to European and Asian capitals and meets bigwigs and he's still very well connected. Does he find this a bit demeaning that he's not representing kind of vested corporate interests rather than Uncle Sam? He says to his friends, he finds it degrading to be doing this on behalf of Pepsi. Now everybody
我的意思是，当时他们在曼哈顿确实有社交名媛舞会。也许现在还有，我不知道。他在乡村俱乐部里和乡村俱乐部里的共和党人混在一起。他为百事可乐工作。他是一种企业大使。因此，他前往欧洲和亚洲的首都，会见大人物，而且他仍然有着极佳的人脉。他是否觉得这有点贬低自己，因为他代表的不是山姆大叔，而是既得企业利益？他向朋友们坦言，他觉得代表百事可乐做这些事有失身份。现在每一个
who knows anything about Nixon will know the side of Nixon, the dark side, the insecurity about his background, the brooding, vengeful nature, the social awkwardness, the inability to forget slights, all of this kind of stuff. He is, I think, I mean, the one reason I find him so interesting and in a weird way, a little bit endearing, is I think he's the embodiment of all the worst banal traits that we all have, or at least all of us on the rest is history. Speak for yourself. Yeah.
对尼克逊有所了解的人都会知道尼克逊的另一面，即黑暗面、对他出身的不安全感、沉郁复仇的性格、社交上的笨拙、无法忘记受到的冷落，诸如此类。我想，我之所以觉得他如此有趣，并且在某种奇怪的层面上有点让人喜爱，是因为我认为他是我们所有人身上所有最糟糕的平庸特质的化身，或者至少是我们这档《历史的 Rest is History》节目里所有人的化身。请代表你自己说话。好吧。
But actually, there's a side of Nixon that comes out now, which is perhaps more admirable side. He hates this new life and the legal business. And he says to his friends, if I have to keep doing this, I will be mentally dead in two years and physically dead in four years. I find it so boring. And some of his friends are actually worried that he would give into depression. So the pioneering black baseball player, Jackie Robinson wrote him a letter, you are good for politics, good for America. Don't let the critics cause you to give up your career. Billy Graham, who has made a few cameo appearances in this series, there are few men whom I have
但实际上，尼克逊现在展露出的一面，也许是更值得赞赏的一面。他痛恨这种新生活和法律业务。他对朋友们说：“如果我必须继续这样做，我将在两年内精神死亡，四年内肉体死亡。我发现这太无聊了。”他的一些朋友甚至担心他会陷入抑郁。因此，黑人棒球先驱杰基·罗宾逊写信给他：你对政治有益，对美国有益。不要让批评者让你放弃你的职业生涯。比利·杰姆，他在本系列节目中客串过几次，他说：很少有人能像我爱你那样去爱你的了。如果你去酗酒或寻求其他任何逃避现实的方式，那将是我能想到的最大的悲剧。他在想什么呢？
loved as I love you. It would be the greatest tragedy I can think of for you to turn to drink or any of these other escapisms. What's he thinking about? Yeah, what's he thinking about? Anyway, Nixon doesn't. They underestimate the thing about him. He's very hardworking.
是的，他在想什么呢？不管怎样，尼克逊没有这么做。人们低估了关于他的一点。他非常努力工作。
He's actually quite resilient. And he spends these years reading Edmund Burke, Machiavelli, Friedrich Nietzsche. He's a serious person, Nixon. He's not just the sort of the joke in the bowling alley in the White House. And there's also a sort of melancholy to him. So he sits alone on his 52nd birthday in his study in New York writing these resolutions on a pad. Set great goals, daily rest, brief vacations, knowledge of all weaknesses, better use of time, begin writing book, articles or speeches on provocative new international and national
他其实相当坚韧。他把这些年都花在阅读埃德蒙·伯克、马基雅维利、弗里德里希·尼采的书上。尼克逊是个严肃的人。他不仅仅是白宫保龄球馆里的一个笑料。他身上也有一种忧郁。因此，在他52岁生日那天，他独自坐在纽约的书房里，在一张便签纸上写下这些决心：设定伟大的目标，每日休息，短暂度假，了解所有弱点，更好地利用时间，开始撰写关于挑衅性国际和国内新议题的书籍、文章或演讲。
issues. And Nixon loves a resolution. There's the sense that you get also with Johnson and with Wallace, that none of them can really function without politics. That without politics, they feel that they're not really themselves. Completely there is. Yeah, absolutely. Because actually, if you wanted to fix Nixon's life, you would say, come on, you've been vice president, that's not bad.
尼克逊对下决心这种事喜爱有加。你会从约翰逊和华莱士身上也感受到这种感觉，即他们没有政治就无法真正运作，如果没有政治，他们就会觉得自己不再是真正的自己。完全是这样。是的，绝对如此。因为实际上，如果你想安排好尼克逊的生活，你会说：得了吧，你当过副总统，这已经很不错了。
Settle down and make loads of money as a New York lawyer, corporate lawyer. You'll be laughing, you'll have a brilliant life. And you won't have people shouting at you and you won't be being nasty to people and stuff and it'll be great, but he can't, he's got the itch. Must give speech on an important international issue, this kind of thing. So actually he throws himself back into it. He despises the politics of Barry Goldwater, libertarian, much more right wing in 1964. But he works for him anyway and works hard for the Republican party candidates. It's a bit like Hubert Humphrey with LBJ, that both of them are biding their time, but
安顿下来，作为一名纽约律师、公司律师赚大笔钱。你会笑口常开，你会过上精彩的生活。你不会让人冲你大喊大叫，你也不用对别人刻薄，这多好啊。但他做不到，他就是有这种戏瘾。必须就一个重要的国际议题发表讲话，诸如此类的事。所以实际上他又重新投入其中。他鄙视1964年自由主义者、立场右得多巴里·戈德华特的政治。但他还是为他工作，并为共和党候选人努力工作。这有点像 Hubert Humphrey 和 LBJ 的关系，他们都在等待时机，但也
also having to suck up stuff they don't agree with to display their loyalty. To an extent, yeah. I mean, Nixon is really, Nixon works what people call the kind of rubber chicken circuit. The rubber Southern chicken. Exactly. If it's Friday night, he's there in Tulsa, Oklahoma, on a holiday inn, making a speech to the Chamber of Commerce. That's his idea of a brilliant night out.
不得不忍受他们并不同意的东西来表现他们的忠诚。某种程度上，是的。我的意思是，尼克逊真的是，尼克逊跑了人们所说的“橡胶鸡巡回赛”。南方的橡胶鸡。没错。如果今天是星期五晚上，他就会出现在俄克拉荷马州塔尔萨的一个假日酒店里，向商会发表讲话。这就是他心目中精彩的夜晚外出。
So in the mid-60s, he visits hundreds and hundreds of groups, especially in the South, because he recognizes that the South is the new battleground for the Republicans. You know, he can make a lot of gains there basically. And he's always very clever. He is conservative, but he's never too conservative. You know, he's never racist, but he intimates to Southern audiences. There's too much federal interference and this kind of thing, but he kind of soft soft law and order. Yeah, law and order. He's clever in how he packages it. So by 1967 or so, he's got a lot of credit with ordinary Republicans, loads of credit. He's the beaten guy who came back, dusted himself down and has put in the hours in the
所以在60年代中期，他拜访了成百上千个团体，特别是在南方，因为他认识到南方是共和党人的新战场。你知道，他基本上可以在那里取得很大的收益。而且他总是非常聪明。他是保守的，但绝不过于保守。你知道，他从不种族主义，但他向南方听众暗示：联邦政府的干预太多了，诸如此类的话，但他的手段比较温和。法律与秩序。是的，法律与秩序。他在包装它的时候很聪明。因此到了1967年前后，他在普通共和党人中赢得了很高的声誉，极高的声誉。他是那个被打倒后卷土重来、拍拍身上的灰尘、并在尽可能没有光彩的地方付出了无数心血的失败者。人们喜欢东山再起。他们确实喜欢。这是一个好故事，不是吗？伟大的美国故事，对吧？是的。所以他对他的家人说，你知道，我在考虑竞选总统，而他们崩溃了。尽可能没有光彩的地方付ossal。人们喜欢东山再起。他们确实喜欢。这是一个好故事，不是吗？伟大的美国故事，对吧？是的。所以他对他的家人说，你知道，我在考虑竞选总统，而他们崩溃了。
most unglamorous places possible. And people like a comeback. They do. It's a good story, doesn't it? Great American story, right? Yeah. So he says to his family, you know, I'm thinking about running for president and they are devastated. places possible. And people like a comeback. They do. It's a good story, doesn't it? Great American story, right? Yeah. So he says to his family, you know, I'm thinking about running for president and they are devastated.
尽可能没有光彩的地方。人们喜欢东山再起。他们确实喜欢。这是一个好故事，不是吗？伟大的美国故事，对吧？是的。所以他对他的家人说，你知道，我在考虑卷土重来竞选总统，而他们崩溃了。
His wife, Pat, who at this point is transmogrified from being in the sort of early fifties, a slightly generic kind of smiling American housewife, now looks like the most miserable person on the planet, like utterly downtrodden. Because he's off every weekend touring the South or whatever. I think life with Dick Nixon is quite hard work. Okay. You know, he's always off reading Edmund Burke and talking about Disraeli, which he does, and plotting political comebacks.
他的妻子帕特，此时已经从50年代初那种略显大众化的、总是面带微笑的美国家庭主妇，变成了一个看起来像是地球上最悲惨的人，显得彻底被压迫。因为他每个周末都要去南方巡回演讲什么的。我认为和迪克·尼克逊一起生活是一件相当辛苦的事。好吧。你知道，他总是去读埃德蒙·伯克，谈论迪斯雷利（他确实这么做），并策划政治复仇。
And actually that's not really the life that she wants. Because what does she want? She wants country clubs and stuff. I think she'd probably prefer the country clubs. stuff. I think she probably prefer the country clubs. Yeah. I mean, who wouldn't, right? I mean, being a presidential candidate's wife is awful. Because their daughters are very glamorous, aren't they?
而这其实并不是她想要的生活。因为她想要什么？她想要乡村俱乐部之类的。我想她大概更喜欢乡村俱乐部。诸如此类的话。我想她大概更喜欢乡村俱乐部。是的。我的意思是，谁不想呢，对吧？当总统候选人的妻子太可怕了。因为他们的女儿们非常迷人，不是吗？
Tricia and Julie. Yeah. Yeah, they're very glamorous. And so people would often say, how is it that Richard Nixon has such glamorous, such glamorous daughters? I think it greatly returns to Nixon's credits, of course. But, um, well, having two lovely daughters, people say that of you, Tom, let's be frank.
翠西亚和朱莉。是的。是的，她们非常迷人。所以人们经常会说，理查德·尼克逊怎么会有如此迷人、如此迷人的女儿呢？我认为这很大程度上要归功于尼克逊，当然。但是，嗯，有两个可爱的女儿，人们也会对你这么说，汤姆，坦白讲。
Anyway, Pat is persuaded by their friends in California. Come on. You can't stand in the way of Dick's dream. So he cranks up his campaign and it's going to be run. And this will be a big thing in his administration. It's run by people who are not really part of the Republican party apparatus. They're his own loyalists. They're his own creatures.
无论如何，帕特被他们在加利福尼亚的朋友劝服了。得了吧。你不能挡迪克梦想的路。于是他开动了他的竞选机器，并且将由特定人员来运行。这将在他的政府中成为一件大事。运行它的人并不是真正的共和党党内机器的一部分。他们是他自己的忠实追随者。他们是他一手提拔的人。
And so that's another reflection of the fact that he is congenitally suspicious. Exactly. That he wants to surround himself with his own creatures. Yes. So he's got these Californian guys, people who know the Watergate story will know the names, H.R. Haldeman, John Ehrlichman. They had been friends since UCLA. Haldeman is an advertising man. They're all about the packaging and the presentation. And traditional Washington insiders distrust and dislike them. They say, who are these guys in the West Coast? You just care about the media. But they are incredibly
所以这反映了另一个事实，即他天生多疑。没错。他希望身边环绕着自己一手提拔的人。是的。所以他有这些加利福尼亚的家伙，熟悉水门事件故事的人会知道这些名字：H·R·霍尔德曼，约翰·埃利希曼。他们自UCLA以来就是朋友。霍尔德曼是个广告人。他们全神贯注于包装和展示。传统的华盛顿内部人士不信任并讨厌他们。他们说，这些西海岸来的家伙是谁？你们只关心媒体。但他们对尼克逊个人极其
loyal to Nixon personally, which is really important to him. Now he's got a couple of problems. Number one, he is seen as a loser because he has lost two elections on the bounce. So he needs to prove he can win. And he says from the beginning, I'm going to enter every single Republican primary where a lot of people at this point are picking and choosing. I will enter and fight in every single state because he's confident that all that rubber chicken circuit work will pay dividends. But also it shows his energy, right? And his commitment to the entirety of the United States. Exactly.
忠诚，这对他来说非常重要。现在他面临几个问题。第一，他被视为一个失败者，因为他连续输掉了两次选举。所以他需要证明自己能够获胜。他从一开始就说：我要参加每一个共和党初选，虽然此时很多人都在挑挑拣拣。我将在每一个州都参选并战斗，因为他坚信所有那些“橡胶鸡巡回赛”的工作都会带来回报。但这同时也展现了他的活力，对吧？以及他对整个美国的承诺。没错。
The second problem is his image as a terrible person, as a terrible human being. So people have always seen Nixon as very aggressive, as a divider and not a uniter. So Nixon, to use his own scornful phrase, he decides to present Nixon as nice guy. So this is where he's going on sandy beaches in his smart black shoes. Exactly.
第二个问题是他的形象像个糟糕的人，一个糟糕的人类。所以人们一直认为尼克逊非常具有攻击性，是个分裂者而不是团结者。因此尼克逊用他自己嘲讽的短语决定将尼克逊塑造成一个好人。所以这就是他穿着帅气的黑皮鞋走在沙滩上的地方。没错。
Just a regular guy with a sort of rictus grin. But also his politics, so his politics at this point are centrist politics. He's Mr. Normal, a bit 1950s, you know, the cities are in flames, it's all kicking off under the Democrats. Wouldn't it be better to get back to life in the mid fifties? That's what I, Dick Nixon, stand for. No mad experiments. No ideological crusades.
只是一个带着僵硬微笑的普通人。但还有他的政治主张，他此时的政治主张是中派政治。他是“正常先生”，有点像50年代的风格，你知道，城市在燃烧，这一切在民主党人统治下闹得沸沸扬扬。回到50年代中期那样的生活不是更好吗？这就是我——迪克·尼克逊——所代表的。没有疯狂的实验。没有意识形态的十字军东征。
Apple pie. The white picket fence. I'm home, honey. All that. Exactly. So on Vietnam, for example, where he'd previously been a hawk and he had previously been very, you know, let's, let's fight this war. Let's do this.
苹果派。白色的栅栏。亲爱的，我回来了。诸如此类。因此，例如在越南问题上，他以前是个鹰派，而且以前非常坚定，让我们、让我们打这场战争。让我们这么做。
After the Tet Offensive, he says to his speech writers, it's pretty obvious. We're not going to win this on the battlefield. Like this is a, this is a right mess. So his line is peace with honor. Which is brilliant, isn't it? Cause what does that mean? Yeah. It doesn't mean anything at all.
在春节攻势之后，他对他的演讲撰稿人说，这相当明显。我们不可能在战场上赢得这场胜利。这简直是一场彻头彻尾的烂摊子。所以他的口号是“体面的和平”。这太妙了，不是吗？因为那是什么意思？是的。这根本没有任何意义。
But when he says that to people, peace, but with honor, they say, oh, that's exactly what I, I love that's exactly what I love. That's brilliant. Love it. And actually the amazing thing is that if you look at the press in 1968, all the coverage, they are persuaded. You know, everybody says, oh, Dick Nixon, we were quite hard on him. He's matured.
但当他对人们说这句话时——和平，但要有尊严——他们会说，哦，这正是我想要的，我太喜欢了，这正是我想要的。这太精彩了。太棒了。而且令人惊奇的是，如果你看看1968年的媒体，所有的报道，他们都被说服了。你知道，每个人都说，哦，迪克·尼克逊，我们之前对他太严厉了。他成熟了。
You know, we've kicked Dick Nixon like a dog, but actually he's not such a bad guy. So Theodore H. White, who wrote The Making of the President in 1960, the great book on presidential campaigns and had been really hard on Nixon said, you know, he's hollow, he's a plastic man. He says, Nixon is now a softer, more mellow, more self-confident, more amusing, well-to-do lawyer statesman. I find him a good man now. Norman Mailer, so Norman Mailer like you Tom, was very impressed by
你知道，我们像对待狗一样踢过迪克·尼克逊，但实际上他并不是个那么坏的人。因此，曾撰写1960年《总统的诞生》（关于总统竞选的伟大著作、曾对尼克逊非常严厉）的西奥多·H·怀特说，你知道，他是空洞的，他是一个塑料人。他说，尼克逊现在是一个更温和、更圆融、更自信、更风趣、家境优渥的律师政治家。我现在觉得他是个好人。诺曼·梅尔，诺曼·梅尔和你一样，汤姆，对
Tricia and Julie. Norman Mailer at this point always writes about himself in the third person. This is in Harper's magazine. It's like Julius Caesar. Like Julius Caesar. Nothing in Mailer's prior view of Nixon had ever prepared him to conceive of a man with two lovely girls. Was it even possible that Nixon was a good man?
翠西亚和朱莉印象深刻。诺曼·梅尔此时总是用第三人称来写自己。这发表在《哈珀斯》杂志上。就像尤利乌斯·恺撒一样。就像尤利乌斯·恺撒。梅尔以前对尼克逊的看法中，没有任何一点能让他准备好去构想一个拥有两个可爱女孩的男人。难道尼克逊真的是个好人吗？
Not a bad man. And my favorite one of these is Dr Hunter S Thompson. Are you a fan of his writing, Tom? I don't know. I've never read him. Okay. So he's the fear and loathing in Las Vegas man. He had a great relationship with Nixon.
不是个坏人。我最喜欢其中之一的是亨特·S·汤普森博士。你是他作品的粉丝吗？我不知道。我从来没读过他的书。好吧。所以他是《拉斯维加斯的恐惧与厌恶》的作者。他与尼克逊有着极好的关系。
Oh, he's the one who said he was so crooked that he wouldn't be able to put his pants on straight. Exactly. We read him in the Watergate episode. Yeah, we did. Hunter S Thompson wrote in 1968, for years I've regarded Nixon's very existence as a monument to all the rancid genes and broken chromosomes that corrupt the possibilities of the American dream. He was a foul caricature of himself, a man with no soul, no inner convictions, with the integrity of
哦，他是那个说尼克逊太狡猾、连裤子都穿不直的人。没错。我们在水门事件那一集中读过他的话。是的，我们读过。亨特·S·汤普森在1968年写道：多年来，我一直将尼克逊的存在视为美国之梦可能性的所有腐朽基因和断裂染色体的纪念碑。他成了他自己的恶劣讽刺画，一个没有灵魂、没有内在信念的人，有着土狼般的廉价正直
a hyena and the style of a poison toad. I've had reviews like that. Just a question. I mean, I know that that Nixon, you know, Watergate and everything. Yeah. All of that. But the reactions to him in the sixties do seem in excess of what he's done up until that point. I mean, he doesn't seem... No, that's the weird thing. He doesn't seem that bad. I mean, relative to some of the other characters that we've been talking about in this series. So it's partly because of anti-communism, it's partly because of his role in anti-communism and what's perceived as red baiting. He had gone for a couple of kind of democratic favorites,
和毒蟾蜍般的风格。我收到过这样的书评。只有一个问题。我的意思是，我知道尼克逊，你知道，水门事件和所有这一切。是的。所有那些。但60年代人们对他的反应似乎超出了他在此之前所做的事情。我的意思是，他看起来并不……不，这就是奇怪的地方。他看起来没有那么糟糕。我的意思是，相对于我们在本系列中一直在谈论的其他一些角色而言。这部分是因为反共主义，部分是因为他在反共主义中的角色以及被视为“打红帽子”的行为。他曾针对过几位民主党宠儿，
most famously a guy called Al Jahiss, and Nixon had actually, I think it's fair to say, exposed him as being, if not a traitor, then at least a fellow traveler. But it seems more than a political reaction. Yeah, it's snobbery. Well, is it? But it's a kind of visceral reaction to him as an individual, that he just seems horrible. I think it's that people feel he embodies all the, what they dislike most about mass culture, mass society. He's common, he's vulgar, he's aggressive, he's partisan. You know,
最著名的是一个叫阿尔·希斯的人，而且尼克逊实际上（我认为这样说很公平）揭露了他即使不是叛徒，至少也是同路人。但它似乎不仅仅是一种政治反应。是的，这是势利。嗯，是吗？但这是一种针对他个人的本能反应，觉得他太可怕了。我认为这是因为人们觉得他体现了大众文化、大众社会中最不受他们喜欢的一切。他粗俗、粗鲁、好斗、有党派偏见。你知道，
I do think there's a fair bit of social and cultural snobbery. He's also, they regard him as charmless, as awkward, socially awkward, as graceless. Maladois. Yeah, Maladois. Exactly. Anyway, Hunter S. Thompson, who had said all that, actually ends up sharing a car with Nixon in the 1968 primaries, they end up talking about American football. Nixon is a real nerd and he knows all the details of like where the
我确实认为这里面有相当多的社会和文化势利。他们还认为他毫无魅力、笨拙、社交笨拙、不够优雅。笨手笨脚。是的，笨手笨脚。没错。不管怎样，曾说过所有那些话的亨特·S·汤普森，最后竟然在1968年的初选中和尼克逊共乘一辆车，他们最后谈论起了美式橄榄球。尼克逊是个真正的书呆子，他知道诸如球员们去哪所大学上学之类的所有细节。亨特·S·汤普森对此惊为天人。他这样评价尼克逊：新尼克逊更加轻松、更具智慧、更加圆融。我到新罕布什尔州时本以为会看到一头狂叫的驴，结果却确信理查德·尼克逊拥有政坛最顶尖的大脑之一。人们会觉得，哇，太棒了。但等他后来开始写水门事件时，他又改变了看法。又改变了看法，完全是这样。所以尼克逊确实有竞争对手。有一个叫纳尔逊·洛克菲勒的人。非常有钱。
players went to college and stuff. Hunter S. Thompson is absolutely bowled over by this. He says of Nixon, the new Nixon is more relaxed, wiser, more mellow. I went to New Hampshire expecting to find a braying ass and I came away convinced that Richard Nixon has one of the best minds in politics. People are like, wow, brilliant. But by the time he comes to write about Watergate, he's changed his mind again. Changed his mind again, exactly. So Nixon does have rivals. There's a guy called Nelson Rockefeller. Very rich.
他相当令人印象深刻。非常令人印象深刻。纽约州州长。他提出了那个关于越南的精彩短语，即美国是一个寻找正义的承诺。哦，对。这是个很好的精彩短语。嗯，他是个令人印象深刻的聪明人，但他是一个富有的东海岸建制派
He's quite impressive. Very impressive. Governor of New York. He comes up, he has that brilliant phrase about Vietnam, that America is a commitment looking for a justification. Oh, right. That's a good nice phrase. Well, he's an impressive and a smart guy, but he's a rich East coast establishment
离婚者，保守派草根阶层基本上认为他是——他们管他叫什么来着？名义上的共和党人（RINO）。好吧。对。又一个“林肯轿车自由主义者”。是的。因此，洛克菲勒不确定是否要参选，他让米特·罗姆尼的父亲乔治·罗姆尼出马。
divorcee, and he is regarded by the conservative grassroots as basically, what do they call them? A rhino Republican in name only. Okay. Right. And yet another limousine liberal. Yeah. So Rockefeller, not sure whether to enter, he gets Mitt Romney's father, George Romney.
他是美国汽车公司的汽车大亨、CEO，是底特律摩门教教会的领袖，密歇根州州长。他代替洛克菲勒参选，但所有人都认为罗姆尼是个白痴。他从越南之行回来后说：我刚刚接受了将军们能给予任何人的最棒的洗脑。于是所有人都说：哦，好吧，如果你要被将军们洗脑，那你显然是个十足的傻瓜。你不能，你不能到处说自己作为总统候选人被洗脑了。这太疯狂了。
He was the big car executive, CEO of American Motors, he was the head of the Mormon church in Detroit, governor of Michigan. He runs in Rockefeller's stead, but everybody thinks that Romney is an idiot. He came back from a trip to Vietnam and said, I just had the greatest brainwashing that anyone can have from the generals. And everybody says, oh, well, if you're going to be brainwashed by the generals, you're obviously a complete fool. You can't be, you can't go around saying you've been brainwashed as a presidential candidate. That's mad.
除非你是《满洲候选人》。是的。嗯，尤金·麦卡锡对乔治·罗姆尼说，他说：我为什么需要洗脑？轻轻漂洗一下就足够了。非常好。于是罗姆尼退出了，尼克逊可以某种程度上轻松通过初选，然后他来到了迈阿密海滩的全国代表大会。对他构成巨大威胁的实际上是罗纳德·里根，我们的老朋友。所以罗纳德·里根此时——不，他发出的那种声音更加强硬。
Unless you're the Manchurian candidate. Yeah. Well, Eugene McCarthy said about George Romney, he says, why did I need a brainwash? A light rinse would have been sufficient. Very good. So Romney pulls out, Nixon's got a sort of, he can cruise through the primaries and then he gets to Miami beach, the convention. And the big threat to him is actually Ronald Reagan, our old friend. So Ronald Reagan at this point, no, that, that noise that he's making is more hard edged.
那是一种法律与秩序的声音。是的，那可能更沙哑一点。可能更沙哑一点。所以里根是南方的宠儿，因为他们把他视为法律与秩序、犯罪的候选人，对民权运动不友好，所有这些。如果他能说服南方代表团抛弃尼克逊，里根可能就有机会获得提名。所以尼克逊必须在南方下大功夫，他基本上拉拢了这家伙，说实话，我认为他算不上我最喜欢的美国历史人物之一。他就是南卡罗来纳州参议员斯特姆·瑟蒙德。斯特姆·瑟蒙德曾任参议员
It's a kind of law and order noise. Yeah, that's more gravelly maybe. More gravelly maybe. So Reagan is the darling of the South because they see him as the candidate of law and order, crime, not friendly to civil rights, all of this. And if he can persuade the Southern delegations to abandon Nixon, Reagan might have a shot at the nomination. So Nixon has to work really hard on the South and he basically enlists this bloke who is actually, I think it's fair to say, not one of my favourite people in American history. He's the Senator from South Carolina, Strom Thurmond. Strom Thurmond was a Senator
一直到大约2020年左右。我的意思是，他听起来就像漫威漫画里的超级反派。他当参议员时已经大约170岁了。他确实是，不是吗？是的。他的政治生涯建立在种族隔离制度之上。如果人们听说在他生命的最末几天，事实证明他至少有一个私生的混血孩子，这大概会让他的种族隔离主义处于
until about 2020 or something. I mean, he sounds like a super villain from a Marvel comic. He was a Senator still when he was about 170 years old. He was, wasn't he? Yeah. He had built his career on segregation. It would astound people to hear that in the final days of his life, it turned out he had at least one out of wedlock mixed race child, which perhaps puts his segregationism into
一个稍微不同的背景之下，这可能会让人们大吃一惊。无论如何，瑟蒙德，尼克逊向瑟蒙德伸出橄榄枝并说：来吧，做我向南方人推销的代办。瑟蒙德说：太棒了，没问题。于是瑟蒙德安排所有南方人与尼克逊会面。尼克逊对他们说：听着，我知道里根是你们的最爱，但你们能从我这里得到你们想要的东西。我知道你们不喜欢美国所走的道路。
a slightly different context. Anyway, Thurmond, Nixon reaches out to Thurmond and says, come on, be my salesman with the Southerners. Thurmond says, great, will do. So Thurmond arranges for all the Southerners to meet Nixon. And Nixon says to them, listen, you know, I know Reagan is your favorite, but you can get what you want from me. I know you don't like the road that America has taken.
我将任命更多保守派法官。我将停止联邦政府的干预。我将停止迎合民权团体。他说，特别是，在学校实现一体化的问题上，我会给你们想要的。他们真的很关心这个对美国听众非常熟悉但在美国以外可能不熟悉的问题，即学校校车接送制度（school busing）。这意味着通过用校车将黑人儿童送到白人地区上学，反之亦然，来实现学校一体化，从而在全市范围内创造融合。白人家长对此恨之入骨。
I will appoint more conservative judges. I will call off the federal government. I will stop pandering to civil rights groups. He says, in particular, I will give you what you want over the integration of schools. They are really concerned about this issue, very familiar to our American listeners, but probably not outside America, of school busing. That means integrating schools by busing black children into white areas and vice versa to create a mix across the city. White parents hate this with a passion.
而尼克逊说：我不同意这样做，我也不会这么做。他们觉得：太好了。你知道，他不是用乔治·华莱士式的言辞来表达这一点的。他纯粹是从实用主义的角度出发。他竭力宣称：你知道，我不是种族主义者，诸如此类的话，但这确实奏效了。他击败了里根的叛乱。南方倒向了他，他显然将赢得提名。但对南方还有一个安抚之举，而且是一个非常有趣的举动。他必须挑选他的副总统，而他挑选了我最喜欢的美国副总统——马里兰州州长斯皮罗·阿格纽。
And Nixon says, I don't agree with it and I won't do it. And they think, great. You know, he doesn't do this in George Wallace style terms. He does it purely in terms of pragmatism. He goes out of his way to say, you know, I'm not a racist and all that stuff, but it works. He defeats the Reagan rebellion. South falls in behind him and he is clearly going to win the nomination. But there's one more sop to the South and a very entertaining one. He has to pick his vice president and he picks my favorite of all America's vice presidents, Spiro Agnew, the governor of Maryland.
现在斯皮罗·阿格纽基本上是个无名小卒。他们在阿格纽被选中的那天在亚特兰大做了一些精彩的街头采访，问街上的人：你们对斯皮罗·阿格纽怎么看？脱颖而出的三个回答是：某种疾病、某种鸡蛋，以及他是那个拥有造船公司的希腊人，也就是亚里士多德·奥纳西斯。斯皮罗·阿格纽确实有希腊血统。他曾是一位温和派的马里兰州州长，但在1968年春季的骚乱之后，他邀请巴尔的摩的黑人领袖来到州首府，并基本上对他们进行了一番严厉的训斥。
Now Spiro Agnew was pretty much a nobody. They did some brilliant Vox pops in Atlanta on the day he was picked, asking people in the street, what do you think about Spiro Agnew? And the three replies that stand out are, it's some kind of disease, it's some kind of egg and he's that Greek that owns that shipbuilding firm, i.e. Aristotle and Assis. Spyro Agnew is indeed Greek extraction. He'd been a centrist, moderate governor of Maryland, but after the riots in the spring of 1968, he invited Baltimore's black leaders to come to the state capital and had basically given them a massive harangue.
他说：发生这一切全都是你们的错。你们没有做足够的工作去批评那些访问河内、大喊大叫、煽动骚乱、烧毁美国、唯恐天下不乱的黑人激进分子。他们对此极为愤怒，全都拂袖而去。随后，阿格纽收到了来自马里兰州选民的大量信件，信中对他说：干得好。你真是个了不起的人。干得好。
And he had said, it's all your fault that this has happened. You haven't done enough to criticize the Hanoi visiting, catawalling, riot inciting, burn America down, black radicals. They were really cross about this and they all walked out. And Agnew was then deluged with letters from the voters of Maryland saying to him, Well done. What a brilliant man you are. Well done.
太棒了。这就是尼克逊基本上选择他的原因吗？这就是尼克逊选择他的原因，因为他来自边境州，而且他对黑人权利领袖态度强硬。从尼克逊的角度来看，这太棒了，因为尼克逊的战略全在于我们现在所说的中产阶级，或者他后来所说的伟大的沉默大多数。所以，他的传记作家、他最近的传记作家约翰·A·法雷尔将其描述为这样一群人：
Fantastic. And is that why Nixon basically picks him? This is why Nixon picks him because he's a border state and because he's been tough on blacks of rights leaders. And this is great from Nixon's point of view, because Nixon's strategy is all about what we would now call middle America or he would later call the great silent majority. So, his biographer, his most recent biographer, John A. Farrell, describes these are people
他们看纳斯卡赛车，看NFL橄榄球，他们去教堂，他们为童子军做志愿者，他们觉得鲍勃·霍珀非常搞笑，他们觉得约翰·韦恩酷毙了。他们认识的孩子正在越南打仗。他们是社会的基石，是普通的美国中产阶级。甚至自愿去越南参战。或者确实自愿去越南参战，完全是这样。你知道，他们喜欢把周末花在钓鱼、打猎上，开着皮卡到处兜风。雪佛兰皮卡。
who they watch NASCAR, they watch the NFL, they go to church, they volunteer for the Boy Scouts, they think Bob Hope is very funny, they think John Wayne is tremendously cool. They know people whose kids are fighting in Vietnam. They are the salt of the earth, ordinary middle Americans. Indeed have volunteered to fight in Vietnam. Or indeed have volunteered to fight in Vietnam, exactly. You know, they like to spend their weekends fishing and hunting and driving around and their pickups and pickups. Chevys.
是的，就是雪佛兰皮卡，诸如此类。我认为尼克逊的超能力在于他懂他们。他本能地懂他们。他不需要民调。他就是知道——因为他某种程度上也是他们中的一员——美国中产阶级害怕什么，他们想要什么。这就是为什么你一开始朗读的那篇演讲，无论人们觉得它多么催人泪下，它都是同类作品中的杰作，因为他一开场就说：当我们审视美国时，我们看到它被烟雾和火焰包裹，我们在夜里听到警笛声。
Yeah, and just Chevys, all of that stuff. And I think Nixon's superpower is that he gets them. He instinctively gets them. He doesn't have to think about it. He doesn't need a poll. He just knows, because he's one of them to some degree, what middle Americans are frightened of what they want. And that's why that speech that you began with, as mortgage, as people might find it, it is a masterpiece of its kind because he starts he says when we look at america we see it's it is enveloped in smoke and flame we hear sirens in the night.
我们看到美国人在远方的战场上死去，这一切，然后他说：我们听到美国人在痛苦中呼喊：我们走这么远就是为了这个吗？接着他说：听听另一个声音。那是喧嚣与叫喊中的平静声音。那是美国绝大多数人的声音，是被遗忘的美国人，是不大喊大叫的人，是不游行示威的人。他们不是种族主义者，也不是心理有病。他们是好人。他们是正派的人。
We see americans dying on distant battlefields abroad all this and then he says we hear the americans crying out in ang, did we come all this way for this? And then he says, listen to another voice. It is the quiet voice and the tumult and the shouting. It is the voice of the great majority of Americans, the forgotten Americans, the non-shouters, the non-demonstrators. They're not racists or sick. They're good people. They're decent people.
他们工作、他们攒钱、他们交税、他们在乎。现在，同样地，很多人听了可能会说：天哪，真令人作呕。但无数人会觉得：哦，太棒了，他懂我。我就是那种人。我愿意认为我是那种人。我的意思是，他在那里并没有提出任何具体的政策，对吧？不，他一点也没有，因为他在越南问题上提出了他的“体面的和平”，鬼才知道那是什么意思。
They work and they save and they pay their taxes and they care. Now again, a lot of people listen to that and may say, God, nauseating, but loads of people think, oh, brilliant, he gets me. I'm one of those people. I like to think I'm one of those people. I mean, he's not offering any hard policies there though, is he? No, he's not at all because he's offering his peace with honor in Vietnam, who knows what that means.
他说：国内不再有骚乱。我们将倾听普通美国人平静的声音。这在实际层面上意味着什么？这没有任何意义，但它有一个极好的结语。我同胞们，美国漫长的黑夜即将结束。我们离开绝望之谷、登上山峰的时刻已经到来。这样我们就能看到黎明的荣耀，这是美国的新一天，也是世界和平与自由的新曙光。
And he says, no more disorder at home. We'll listen to the still quiet voice of the ordinary Americans. And what does that mean in practical terms? It doesn't mean anything, but it's got a great peroration. My fellow Americans, the long dark night for America is about to end. The time has come for us to leave the valley of despair and climb the mountain. So we may see the glory of the dawn, a new day for America and a new dawn for peace and freedom in the world.
我的意思是，那是对马丁·路德·金的抄袭。这显然是彻头彻尾的抄袭。谁能想到理查德·尼克逊的演讲撰稿人……这就像猴子抄袭披头士乐队一样。是的。或者尼克逊才是披头士？而马丁·路德·金是……我不这么认为。
I mean that is a rip-off of Martin Luther King. It's clearly a total rip-off. Who would have thought that Richard Nixon's speech writers... It's like the monkeys ripping off the Beatles. Yeah. Or is Nixon the Beatles? And is Martin Luther King... I don't think so.
马丁·路德·金是个骗子吗？我不这么认为。但关键是，对吧，这是我最喜欢的部分。这是一次巨大的成功，共和党代表大会。尼克逊，中产阶级的人，既不极端也不是这样。他挺身而出，成为了他们心目中的总统人选。他是赢得大选的绝对热门。但这就是窥探尼克逊灵魂的窗口。所以事后，他兴奋极了，正如他在这些活动之后一贯的那样。他想说话，他不想去睡觉。
Is Martin Luther King aca-bilk? I don't think so. But here's the thing, right, this is my favourite bit about this. It's been a tremendous success, the Republican convention. Nixon, the man of middle America, not extreme or this. He's come forward and he's their choice of president. He's a massive favourite to win the election. But here's the window into Nixon's soul. So afterwards, he's absolutely buzzing, as he always is after these. He wants to talk, he won't go to bed.
而且他显然不想跟帕特说话。他对跟帕特说话毫无兴趣。所以在凌晨一点半，他打电话给演讲撰稿人、后来的专栏作家威廉·萨菲尔。他对他说：来我的套房喝一杯。于是萨菲尔来到了尼克逊的套房。尼克逊站在那里，出神地望着窗外，陷入沉思。
And he obviously doesn't want to talk to Pat. He's got no interest in talking to Pat. So at 1.30 in the morning, he calls the speechwriter and later columnist, William Sapphire. And he says, come to my suite for a drink. So Sapphire comes up to Nixon's. Nixon's sweet. Nixon's standing there kind of staring out of the window, lost in thought.
神情紧张。神情紧张。他对萨菲尔说：他们不会喜欢那个演讲的，对吧？他是萨默塞特人吗？他们不会喜欢那个演讲的。这就像我们模仿的约翰·亚当斯的嗓音一样。他们说我既聪明又冷静、 nice 且安详，然后当我向他们展示我知道人们的感受时，这把他们给气死了。
Looking intense. Looking intense. And he says to Safa, they won't like their speech, will they? Is he from Somerset? They won't like that speech. It's like the John Adams voice that we did. They call me intelligent and cool and nice and serene. And then it kills them when I show them I know how people feel.
神情严肃。神情严肃。他对萨法说，他们不会喜欢他的演讲，对吧？他是萨默塞特人吗？他们不会喜欢那场演讲的。这就像我们做过的约翰·亚当斯的嗓音。他们说我聪明、冷酷、友善、宁静。当我向他们展示我知道人们的感受时，他们简直气炸了。
I could write a speech like that and they hate me for it. That's the thing. He says they won't like it. The New York Times and those boys, Theo get your bleeping machine ready. **** them, says Nixon. None of them could write a speech like that and they hate me for it. Now it's kind of bonkers on the most triumphant night of his career that he is sunk in this terrible self-pity. And he goes on like this for an hour and a half. Sapphire gets away at three o'clock in the morning and the last thing he hears, year that he is sunk in this terrible self-pity and he goes on like this for an hour and a half. Sapphire gets away at three o'clock in the morning and the last thing he hears is Nixon as he leaves the apartment is Nixon saying rather plaintively to his Secret Service bodyguard,
我可以写出那样的演讲稿，而他们却因此恨我。这就是问题所在。他说他们不会喜欢的。《纽约时报》和那帮人，西奥，准备好你的录音机。去他妈的，尼克松说。他们谁也写不出那样的演讲稿，而他们却因此恨我。现在，在他职业生涯中最辉煌的夜晚，他却陷入这种可怕的自怜之中，这实在有点荒谬。他这样絮叨了一个半小时。莎菲尔在凌晨三点脱身，他听到的最后一句，在这一年里，他陷入了这种可怕的自怜之中，他这样絮叨了一个半小时。莎菲尔在凌晨三点脱身，他听到的最后一句话是尼克松在离开公寓时说的，
do you know anywhere where I could get a glass of milk? That is Nixon. So not groovy. That is Nixon. That is what a brilliant man he was. So he leaves the convention on an absolute high. Then three weeks later, as we heard last time, things get even better for him. The Democrats self-immolate in Chicago.
你知道哪里能买到一杯牛奶吗？这就是尼克松。一点也不酷。这就是尼克松。这就是他曾经多么才华横溢。因此，他在绝对的高潮中离开了大会。然后就在三周后，正如我们上次听到的那样，情况对他来说变得更好了。民主党人在芝加哥自取灭亡。
The violence, the chaos at the convention, all of this. He now has a double digit lead in the polls. It seems that he can't be stopped. That victory is inevitable. But is it? Is there a twist in the tale, Tom? Is there a twist in the tale? Well, let's take a break and when we come back, we'll find out.
暴力，大会上的混乱，所有这一切。他在民意调查中的领先优势现在达到了两位数。看起来他已经势不可挡了。胜利似乎是不可避免的。但真的是这样吗？故事会有反转吗，汤姆？故事会有反转吗？好吧，我们休息一下，回来后就会揭晓。
Hello and welcome back to the final section of our epic on America in 1968 and Dominic, we are in the presidential campaign. It's Humphrey against Nixon and Nixon, I mean, he's in a good place. He's in a really good place. Miles ahead Humphrey's trailing. He's being heckled by anti-war protesters everywhere he goes. Dump the hump. Calling him a murderer. I mean, it's awful for him.
大家好，欢迎回到我们关于1968年美国宏大历史的最后一节，多米尼克，我们正处于总统竞选之中。这是汉弗莱对阵尼克松，尼克松，我的意思是，他的处境很好。他处境真的很好。遥遥领先，汉弗莱落后。他走到哪儿都被反战抗议者起哄。抛弃汉普。叫他杀人犯。我的意思是，这对他是件可怕的事。
Brilliant for Nixon, but you, you hinted at a twist in the tail. So is there a twist in the tail? Tom, there's more than one twist. I've got as many twists as you can take. It's a corkscrew. It's a roller coaster. Like Nixon himself, right? So crooked.
对尼克松来说太棒了，但你，你暗示了故事会有反转。所以故事真的有反转吗？汤姆，反转不止一个。我有你能承受的各种反转。它就像开瓶器一样曲折。就像过山车一样。就像尼克松本人一样，对吧？那么狡猾。
He's like a corkscrew. He can't take his own pants off. Yes. Pretty pants. Can't screw his pants on straight. That's right. Yeah. Of course, he should have had George Wallace's pants in the Wallace episode because it's really cool. Shiny pants.
他就像个开瓶器。他连自己的裤子都脱不下来。是的。漂亮的裤子。裤子都穿不直。没毛病。是的。当然，他在华盛顿那一集里本该穿乔治·华盛顿的裤子，因为那真的很酷。闪亮的裤子。
There's a lot of pants based action in this. That's America though, isn't it? That's just America. Malcolm Turnbull as well, losing his pants. No, it wasn't Malcolm Turnbull. Malcolm Fraser. Malcolm Fraser. Sorry. Yeah. Apologies to Malcolm Turnbull. Yeah. Memphis, Tennessee. Come on. We've clearly been recording this for too long. We're just free-forming. Gibbering. Right. So Nixon's plan, because he's so far ahead in the polls, he's going to fight a very tightly
这里面有很多关于裤子的情节。不过这就是美国，不是吗？这就是美国。马尔科姆·特恩布尔也是，把裤子弄丢了。不，那不是马尔科姆·特恩布尔。马尔科姆·弗雷泽。马尔科姆·弗雷泽。抱歉。是的。向马尔科姆·特恩布尔道歉。是的。田纳西州孟菲斯。得了吧。我们录这个显然录得太久了。我们都在自由发挥了。胡言乱语。好吧。所以尼克松的计划是，因为他在民调中遥遥领先，他将进行一场极其严密
controlled, very conservative campaign, not throw it away. So like carrying a Ming vase, that strategy. Exactly. And the reason it's worth dwelling on Nixon's campaign is that it is the prototype really for all subsequent presidential campaigns. So the key person is Haldeman. Haldeman, H.R. Haldeman, who ends up becoming his White House kind of chief of staff.
控制的、非常保守的竞选，绝不把它搞砸。所以那个策略就像捧着一只明代花瓶。完全正确。值得深入探讨尼克松竞选的原因在于，它实际上是所有后来总统竞选的原型。所以关键人物是哈尔德曼。哈尔德曼，H.R.·哈尔德曼，他最终成为了他白宫的幕僚长。
Haldeman was a Christian scientist. He's a very crew cut, very square kind of bloke. He worked for J. Walsh Thompson ad agency in Los Angeles. And Haldeman said, we're going to break with all previous political campaigns. We will, and I quote, move out of the dark ages and into the brave new world of the omnipresent eye. So not a million miles from Abbie Hoffman, who likewise has a sense of the power of television. I mean, that's what I find so interesting about this series is the kind of unexpected
哈尔德曼是一名基督教科学派信徒。他是一个留着平头、非常死板的家伙。他曾在洛杉矶的J·沃尔特·汤普森广告公司工作。哈尔德曼说，我们要与以往所有的政治竞选决裂。我们将，我引用原话，走出黑暗时代，迈向无所不在之眼的勇敢新世界。所以这和艾比·霍夫曼相差不远，后者同样具有对电视力量的敏锐感知。我的意思是，我觉得这个系列最有趣的地方在于这种意想不到的
crossovers from left to right and from the countercultural to the very, very mainstream. I don't actually think that's a ridiculous comparison at all. I think that awareness of the sort of Marshall McLuhan kind of era. Yeah, all of that. The medium is the message. Hoffman and the EPS did believe it and Haldeman and Nixon absolutely believe it. So Haldeman says, look, all presidential candidates waste their time going on these rallies like Robert Kennedy had been doing. This is a complete and utter, you just get knackered, you get cross. You know, what's the point?
从左翼到右翼，从反文化到极度主流的交叉融合。我其实觉得这个对比一点也不荒谬。我认为对马歇尔·麦克卢汉那种时代的这种认知。是的，所有这些。媒介即讯息。霍夫曼和进步党人绝对相信这一点，哈尔德曼和尼克松也绝对相信这一点。所以哈尔德曼说，看，所有总统候选人都把时间浪费在像罗伯特·肯尼迪一直在做的那种集会上。这完全是彻底的浪费，你会精疲力竭，你会生气。你知道，有什么意义呢？
Just do one event today for forms sake, after Haldeman, Nixon would have done none and do everything else on television. And the way they do the TV, they get a guy called Roger Iles, who ends up becoming the founding CEO of Fox News. Iles designs these shows where Nixon stands in this kind of little arena surrounded by voters. And he answers their questions and they pay for 10 of these on network TV. And Iles said, look, the way this works is basically, even if you don't support Nixon,
今天为了走过场只做一个活动，照哈尔德曼的主意，尼克松本可以一个都不做，把其他一切都放到电视上。他们制作电视节目的方式是，找了一个叫罗杰·艾尔斯的人，他后来成为了福克斯新闻的创始CEO。艾尔斯设计了这些节目，尼克松站在这种被选民包围的小竞技场里。他回答他们的问题，他们在全国电视网买下了10期这样的节目。艾尔斯说，看，这背后的运作方式基本上是，即使你不支持尼克松，
subliminally you end up rooting for him because he's surrounded by people. They're all sitting, he's standing. He's like, it's like he's at bay in an arena. So like Tony Blair's masochism strategy. Tony Blair's masochism strategy is precisely this. He is alone. He is standing while all others are seated. He is surrounded by people looking into the pit at him.
潜意识里你最终也会支持他，因为他被人群包围着。他们都坐着，而他站着。他就像，就像他在竞技场里被逼入绝境。所以这就像托尼·布莱尔的受虐狂策略。托尼·布莱尔的受虐狂策略正是如此。他孤身一人。当所有其他人坐着时，他站着。他被人们环绕着，人们从深坑里注视着他。
And most people would think of that as a nightmare. That's what Iles says. Now Iles tells this to a young writer called Joe McGuinness. Joe McGuinness is in his early 20s and unbelievably he gets complete access to the Nixon campaign and he writes a book about it called The Selling of the President, which is a wonderful book to read if you're interested in this campaign or campaigning generally, because never before had anyone lifted the lid on the extraordinary cynicism of a presidential campaign. So Iles has this wonderful monologue to his staff and he says to them, our candidate,
大多数人会把这视为一场噩梦。艾尔斯就是这么说的。现在，艾尔斯把这个告诉了一个年轻的作家叫乔·麦金尼斯。乔·麦金尼斯二十出头，令人难以置信的是，他获得了全面接触尼克松竞选团队的权限，并写了一本关于它的书，名为《兜售总统》，如果你对这次竞选或一般意义上的竞选感兴趣，这是一本非常精彩的书，因为此前从未有人揭开过总统竞选那不同寻常的愤世嫉俗的面纱。所以艾尔斯对他的员工有一段精彩的独白，他对他们说，我们的候选人，
people think he's really boring, a pain in the ass. They look at him as the kind of kid who always carried a book bag, who was 42 years old the day he was born. They figured that other kids got footballs for Christmas. Nixon got a briefcase and he loved it. Of course, George Wallace would have thrown him into the river with that briefcase. Is Nixon listening to this? No, yeah. He's just sitting there looking miserable while they're talking about it. Oh, they're dumping on Dick Nixon again.
人们觉得他真的很无聊，是个讨厌鬼。他们把他看作那种总是背着书包、出生那天就42岁的孩子。他们觉得其他孩子圣诞节收到的是足球。尼克松收到的是公文包，而且他爱死它了。当然，乔·华盛顿会带着那个公文包把他扔进河里。尼克松在听这个吗？不，是的。当他们谈论时，他只是坐在那里显得很悲伤。哦，他们又在贬低迪克·尼克松了。
miserable while they're talking about him. Oh, they're dumping on Dick Nixon again. He looks like somebody hung him in a closet overnight. He jumps out in the morning with his suit all bunched up and he starts running around saying, I want to be president. Wow. And this is the guy he's rooting for Nixon. Anyway, so they basically know this and they package Nixon, they sell him. One of Nixon's ad directors said to Jeremy Guinness, we've deliberately set out to make our ads,
当他们谈论他时，他显得闷闷不乐。哦，他们又在贬低迪克·尼克松了。他看起来就像有人连夜把他挂在衣橱里一样。他早上跳出来，西装皱巴巴的，然后开始跑来跑去说，我想当总统。哇。而这就是他所支持的尼克松。无论如何，所以他们基本上知道这一点，他们把尼克松打包，把他兜售出去。尼克松的一位广告总监对杰里·麦金尼斯说，我们刻意将我们的广告制作成，
and I quote, cheap and vulgar to appeal to the lowest common denominator of American taste. But that's a fascinating, that Nixon's own propagandists have a certain kind of snobbish contempt for him. Yeah, of course. I know it is extraordinary. And actually the thing about the ad guy, if you look at the Nixon ads, they are unbelievable because they're not cheap and vulgar.
我引用原话，低级庸俗，以迎合美国品味的最低共同分母。但这是一个令人着迷的现象，尼克松自己的宣传人员对他有一种某种势利轻蔑的态度。是的，当然。我知道这太不可思议了。实际上，关于广告那个家伙，如果你看看尼克松的广告，它们简直不可思议，因为它们一点也不低级庸俗。
They are brilliant. They are these kind of avant-garde montages. You should watch them, Tom. Well, have they're a bit like a kind of doors video. They're like people screaming. It's like apocalypseocalypse Now. Yeah. It's creating the sense of disorder. And then at the end, it projects Nixon as the only solution to all this. So kind of shots of people sobbing in the streets, being hit over the head by cops, GIs in Vietnam. And then
它们太棒了。它们是那种前卫的蒙太奇。你应该看看，汤姆。好吧，它们有点像大门乐队的录像带。它们就像人们在尖叫。这就像《现代启示录》。是的。它营造出一种无序感。然后在最后，它将尼克松投射为解决这一切的唯一方案。所以有点像人们在街头啜泣、被警察殴打、越南美军士兵的镜头。然后
the slogan, the tagline is, this time vote like your whole world. That was Somerset again. This time, vote like your whole world. That was the summer set again. Go for it Dominic. This time vote like your whole world depended on it. I mean that is how Americans speak, let's be honest. Well that's how the founding fathers spoke. So if it's good enough for the founding fathers, it's good enough for us. So anyway, listen, back to the ads.
口号，标语是，这一次投票就像你的整个世界。那又是萨默塞特。这一次，投票就像你的整个世界。又是那个萨默塞特。来吧，多米尼克。这一次投票就像你的整个世界都押在它上面一样。我的说实话，这就是美国人的说话方式。好吧，这就是国父们的说话方式。所以如果它对国父们足够好，对我们就足够好。所以无论如何，听着，回到广告上。
All this raises a crucial question and this is the question that academics are most interested in. This is a key moment in the Republican Party's move to the right, Nixon's embrace of a law and order campaign. And is it, as many historians believe, all about racism? Because of course, this is against the backdrop of so many riots, of the kind of fragmentation of the civil rights movement, but also the Wallace campaign, because Wallace is making so many of the civil rights movement, but also the Wallace campaign, because Wallace is making so many similar sounding arguments. So here's the interesting thing. We know that Nixon did say racist things in the White House.
所有这一切引发了一个至关重要的问题，这也是学者们最感兴趣的问题。这是共和党向右转的关键时刻，尼克松拥抱了法律与秩序竞选。正如许多历史学家所认为的那样，这完全是关于种族主义吗？因为当然，这是在无数骚乱、民权运动碎片化的背景下发生的，同时还有华盛顿的竞选，因为华盛顿提出了许多类似的观点。所以有趣的是。我们知道尼克松在白宫确实说过种族主义的话。
I mean, he's on tape doing it. That said, his record actually up to this point is pretty good. He'd supported the Civil Rights Act, fair housing and this kind of thing. We heard him sampling Martin Luther King in the previous half. He has this thing, doesn't he, where he's always saying, I see a day, which is obviously a kind of riff on I have a dream. And he repeats it over and over again in a kind of cod Martin Luther King way. Yeah, but that's just rhetorical larceny. I don't think he's deliberately trying to evoke.
我的意思是，有录音为证。话虽如此，实际上他到目前为止的记录相当不错。他支持过《民权法案》、公平住房法案以及诸如此类的东西。我们在前一半听到他引用马丁·路德·金。他有个习惯，不是吗，他总是说，我看到有一天，这显然是对“我有一个梦想”的某种模仿。他用一种山寨马丁·路德·金的方式一遍又一遍地重复它。是的，但那只是修辞上的盗窃。我不认为他是故意试图唤起。
Do you not think, I think that in the wake of Martin Luther King's murder, to echo his rhetorical style so overtly, I mean, you can't think that people aren't going to notice it and you're kind of making a point with it. I'm not, I'm not so sure because I think in the 50s and 60s, that style is very common among politicians. So Kennedy spoke in a very repetitive, not I have a dream. But Norman Mailer noticed it. Norman Mailer said he is... Copying Martin Luther King. Copying Martin Luther King. He's suddenly begun it and he says it's basically it was since King's assassination.
你不这么认为吗？我认为在马丁·路德·金遇刺之后，如此公开地模仿他的修辞风格，我的意思是，你不可能认为人们不会注意到这一点，你其实是在用它表达某种观点。我不是，我不是那么确定，因为我认为在50年代和60年代，这种风格在政客中非常普遍。所以肯尼迪说话也非常重复，虽然不是“我有一个梦想”。但诺曼·梅勒注意到了。诺曼·梅勒说他是……
That's interesting. I think the real question though is, is he just blowing a dog whistle? So he says to his aides, you know, I'm not just going to copy Wallace, we're going to have to be more sophisticated than Wallace. But at the same time, he is competing for voters with Wallace in the sort of sunbelt states, the border states and so on, or places like Florida or the Carolinas, with this message of strong defense, traditional values, opposition to school busing, law and order.
模仿马丁·路德·金。模仿马丁·路德·金。他突然开始了，并且他说这基本上是从金遇刺以来就开始的。这很有趣。不过我认为真正的问题是，他是在吹响隐性狗哨吗？所以他对助手们说，你知道，我不只是要效仿华盛顿，我们必须比华盛顿更老练。但与此同时，他在阳光地带州、边境州等地方，或者像佛罗里达或卡罗莱纳州这样的地方，带着强力国防、传统价值观、反对学校校车接送、法律与秩序的信息，与华盛顿争夺选民。
And some historians now, when you open a book about this campaign, will say, this is just coded racism. Nixon is getting into the gutter with Wallace. Now at one level, I think that is actually a little bit unfair, because I think it is completely legitimate to worry about law and order, given that the crime figures have gone through the roof. And frankly, hundreds of people have been killed in riots since 1964. Nixon's ads don't show black rioters, they only ever show white rioters. In his speeches, he never ever mentions race really. He never says anything racist. So you could say, well, you know, he's been very harshly treated. On the other hand,
现在有些历史学家，当你翻开一本关于这次竞选的书时，会说，这只是带有密码的种族主义。尼克松在和华盛顿同流合污。在某种程度上，我认为这其实有点不公平，因为我认为考虑到犯罪率已经飙升，担心法律与秩序是完全合法的。坦率地说，自1964年以来，已有数百人在骚乱中丧生。尼克松的广告没有展示黑人暴徒，他们展示的永远是白人暴徒。在他的演讲中，他从来没有真正提及种族。他从未说过任何种族主义的话。所以你可以说，好吧，你知道，他受到了非常严厉的对待。另一方面，
there is no getting away, I think, from the fact that law and order is also code for black unrest in the inner cities. And Nixon isn't campaigning in a vacuum. He's campaigning in a world in which Reagan and Wallace are saying similar things. And we know from Haldeman's notes that Nixon was actually quite cynical about this. Right. Well, cynicism is the word. Yeah. Isn't it? So Haldeman writes, Irish, Ital, Pole pole mechs are afraid of Negroes, need stronger
我认为无可否认的事实是，法律与秩序也是内城黑人动乱的代名词。而且尼克松并非在真空中竞选。他是在里根和华盛顿发表类似言论的世界中竞选的。我们从哈尔德曼的笔记中知道，尼克松对此实际上相当愤世嫉俗。没错。好吧，愤世嫉俗就是这个词。是的。不是吗？所以哈尔德曼写道，爱尔兰人、意大利人、波兰人、墨西哥人害怕黑人，需要在这个问题上采取更强硬的立场，必须做点什么，必须榨干华盛顿的选票。然后有一份臭名昭著的关于尼克松本人排练电视广告的记录。电视广告以他的一句话结束，问题的核心是我们学校的法律与秩序。然后他结束了排练，接着自言自语道，没错，这正好点中要害。这全关乎法律与秩序以及外面那些该死的黑人波多黎各群体。我的意思是，从最愤世嫉俗的意义上讲，他的目标显然是进行三方平衡。是的，就是这个词。
position on this, must do something, must dry up Wallace vote. And then there's an infamous account of Nixon himself rehearsing a TV ad. The TV ad ends with him saying, the heart of the problem is law and order in our schools. And then he finishes the rehearsal and then he says to himself, yep, that hits it right on the nose. It's all about law and order and the damn Negro Puerto Rican groups out there. I mean, clearly his aim in the most cynical sense is to triangulate. Yeah, that's the word.
为了吸引华盛顿的选民群体。然而与此同时，我的意思是，他确实在表达进步的情绪，不是吗？他确实在呼应马丁·路德·金的语言。所以从竞选的角度来看，我的意思是，不一定是道德角度，但从竞选的角度来看，这是一个绝妙的策略。是的，非常有效。顺便说一句，对于那些在你提到进步情绪时挑起眉毛的人，他说，我们不能变成两个国家，一个黑人，一个白人。
To appeal to the Wallace constituency. And yet at the same time, I mean, he is articulating progressive sentiments, isn't he? And he is echoing the language of Martin Luther King. So from a campaigning point of view, I mean, not necessarily a moral point of view, but from a campaigning point of view, it's a brilliant strategy. Yeah, it's very effective. I mean, by the way, for the people who are raising their eyebrows when you said progressive sentiments, he says, we can't become two nations, one black, one white.
我们必须满怀同情和信念采取行动，将美国梦带到贫民窟。然后他在费城郊区对白人选民发表了一场精彩的演讲。当我们到达费城做节目时，我们会向费城的观众发表类似的进步演讲，对吧？尼克松对这些观众说，你们非常幸运。你知道，你们是非常富有的人，但在伟大的美国城市里，有着所谓的“可怕的贫困”。有穷人。
We must move with compassion and conviction to bring the American dream to the ghetto. And then there's an amazing speech that he gives to white voters in suburban Philadelphia. We will be giving similar kinds of progressive speeches, won't we? To the audience in Philadelphia when we arrive there to do our show. Nixon says to this audience, you're very fortunate. You know, you're very affluent people, but in the great cities of America, there is quote, terrible poverty. There are poor people.
有些人没有机会，没有你们曾有过的机会。他明确对他们说，你们不能坐在房子里，对自己的命运安于现状。除非对我们所有人来说这是一个好国家，否则这对我们任何人来说都不是一个好国家。那番话，你知道的，我一开始引用的那段接受提名的演讲，那个孩子，也就是尼克松本人，与那些没有他那样机会的孩子们形成了对比。是的，完全正确。所以这就是它的精妙之处。这就是让尼克松如此
There are people who haven't had a chance, the chance that you've had. And he says to them explicitly, you can't sit in your houses and just be comfortable with your lot. This won't be a good country for any of us to live in until it's a good country for all of us to live in. And that talk, you know, the passage from the acceptance speech that I began with, that child, which is Nixon himself, is counterpointed to children who don't have the chances that he had. Yes, exactly. So that's the brilliance of it. This is what makes Nixon so
迷人的地方，我想不出现代美国历史上，或者英国历史上，还有多少其他人物，能如此擅长同时向不同的受众传达不同的信息。而且某种程度上，只有当你的耳朵对狗哨声调谐时，才能听到这些信息，我想是的。完全正确。这是一场极其愤世嫉俗的竞选，但正如你之前提到的，这里有一个问题。与民主党人相比，它实际上非常无聊。
fascinating is that I can't think of many other characters in modern American history, or indeed British history, who are so good at sending different messages to different audiences at the same time. And which can only be heard in a sense by, you know, if your ear is attuned to the dog whistle, I suppose. Exactly. This is a brilliantly cynical campaign, but there is a problem you alluded to earlier. It's actually very boring compared with the Democrats.
你知道，尼克松只是在电视演播室消毒过的氛围中四处走动。正如乔·麦金尼斯在《兜售总统》中所说，基本上就好像他在一个巨蛋体育馆里，那里风永远不会吹，温度从不升降，球在人造草坪上永远不会发生不规则的反弹。记者们开始指出这一点，他们变得非常，基本上对他感到厌倦了。是的，好吧，如果他们跟着民主党人，跟着尼克松肯定会觉得无聊。实际上，当我们进入秋季时，汉弗莱开始慢慢赶上。
You know, Nixon's just going around in the sanitised atmosphere of the TV studio. As Joe McGuinness said in the Selling of the president, it's as though basically he was in an Astrodome where the wind would never blow, the temperature never rise and fall and the ball never bounce erratically on the artificial grass. And the press start to point this out and they become very, they become basically bored with him. Yeah, well if they're following the Democrats, they're bound to be bored following Nixon. And actually as we get into the autumn, Humphrey starts to inch back.
经济，你知道，依然相当不错。他仍然拥有庞大的民主党机器。工人们站在他这边。如果他能激发他们的斗志，汉弗莱快没钱了，他在9月30日花完了最后五十万美元，在盐湖城买下了电视网时间发表了一场演讲。在这场演讲中，他只是想，去他的，我要豁出去了。他在演讲中与林登·约翰逊（LBJ）决裂。
The economy, you know, is still pretty good. He's still got the big democratic machine. He's got the unions on his side. If he can fire them up, he's running out of money, Humphrey, and he spends his last half a million dollars on the 30th of September to buy network time for a speech he's giving in Salt Lake City. And in this speech, he just thinks, Soda, I'm going to go for it. And he breaks with LBJ in the speech.
关于越南。关于越南，他说，我将停止对北方的轰炸。他第一次违背了政府的政策。这实际上打破了僵局，因为它结束了针对他的抗议，自由派捐赠者开始给他钱，工人们现在开始担心乔·华盛顿在蓝领民主党人中取得突破。所以他们开始启动他们的机器。随着我们进入十月，有一种感觉，局势
On Vietnam. On Vietnam, he says, I will stop the bombing of the North. For the first time, he goes against the administration's policy. And that actually breaks the logjam as it were, because it ends the protests against him, liberal donors start to give him money, The unions are now worried about George Wallace making inroads among kind of blue collar Democrats. So they start cranking up their machines. And as we get into October, there's a sense that all the time, the ground is
在每天每时每刻突然发生变化，汉弗莱正在蚕食尼克松的领先优势。人们是不是开始拿它与哈里·杜鲁门对托马斯·E·杜威的那场著名胜利相提并论了？是的，完全正确。然后实际上，你知道吗？人们是不是开始拿它与哈里·杜鲁门对托马斯·E·杜威的那场著名胜利相提并论了？是的，完全正确。然后实际上，你知道吗？
shifting suddenly day by day, Humphrey is eating into Nixon's lead. Aren't parallels starting to be drawn with Harry Truman's famous victory against Thomas G. Dewey? Yes, exactly. Then actually, do you know what? Aren't parallels starting to be drawn with Harry Truman's famous victory against Thomas G. Dewey? Yes, exactly. Then actually, do you know what? Humphrey has all the momentum suddenly because he's been written off and stamped on for so
汉弗莱突然士气大振，因为他被看扁和打压了这么久，现在的故事是他在最后一分钟力挽狂澜，民意调查的差距一直在缩小，尼克松甚至对他的助手说，突发事件，突发事件可能会在这上面毁了我们。当然，这就把我们带回了贯穿整个系列的问题，那就是越南。这也把我们带到了关于尼克松胜利的巨大阴谋论。越南一直是个僵局，整整一年血腥得难以置信的僵局。北越在春节攻势中损失了数万名士兵，一直在舔舐伤口。
long and now the story is he's pulled it out at the last minute and the polls are narrowing all the time and Nixon actually says to his aides, events, events could kill us in this. And of course, this brings us back to the issue that's been there all through this series, which is Vietnam. And this takes us to the great conspiracy theory about Nixon's victory. Vietnam has been a stalemate, an incredibly bloody stalemate all year. The North Vietnamese lost tens of thousands of men in the Tet offensive and they've been licking their wounds.
但与此同时，17000名美国军人在1968年失去了生命，这是战争中最糟糕、最血腥的一年。约翰逊正坐在白宫里。现在他的态度非常复杂。按理说，他应该支持汉弗莱，他的副总统，但约翰逊是个可怕的恶霸，他有点喜欢打压休伯特，他身上有这样一部分，我想如果你知道休伯特输了，他其实根本不在乎，他觉得休伯特简直就是个彻头彻尾的失败者。所以卢克·尼克特的书到处都在讲
But at the same time, 17,000 American servicemen will lose their lives in 1968, the worst bloodiest year of the war. Johnson's sitting there in the White House. Now his attitude is very complicated. On paper, he ought to favor Humphrey, his vice president, but Johnson is a dreadful bully and he kind of enjoys stamping on Hubert and this part of him I think that would be you know if Hubert loses he couldn't care less really he thinks Hubert is just a dead loss. So the Nickter book is all over the fact that
林登·约翰逊希望尼克松赢，你对这种说法相信多少？其实我稍微相信一点，我认为林登·约翰逊确实左右为难，因为正如我们之前所说，林登·约翰逊和尼克松是相似的性格。尼克松，我们知道他个子不高。他向林登·约翰逊保证，我会维护你的政策。我永远不会批评你。他确实没批评，不是吗？他确实没有。那本卢克·尼克特的书里有很多关于比利·格雷厄姆作为两人之间穿针引线的中间人的内容，我认为那是真的。所以林登·约翰逊左右为难。他是个终身民主党人。当然他希望他的盟友赢。另一方面，在汉弗莱和尼克松这两人中，
LBJ wants Nixon to win how much credence do you give to that? I think a little bit of credence actually I think LBJ is genuinely torn because as we said before LBJ and Nixon are similar personalities. Nixon, we know that he is short. He promised LBJ, I will uphold your policy. I will never criticize you. And he doesn't, does he? And he doesn't. And there's a lot of stuff in that Luke Nick to book about Billy Graham as a go
他最终对尼克松更有敬意，因为他完全不尊重汉弗莱。所以他犹豫不决，整个秋天人们都在猜测，你知道，林登·约翰逊仍然是总统。
between the two men, which I think is true. So LBJ is torn. He's a lifelong Democrats. Of course he wants his allies to win. On the other hand of the two, Humphrey and Nixon. I think he has more respect for Nixon ultimately, because he has no respect for Humphrey at all. So he's undecided and all autumn people are wondering, you know, Lyndon Johnson is still the president.
他会干预这场竞选吗？会有十月惊奇来改变整个叙事吗？然后就在10月31日，万圣节，重磅炸弹来了，汤姆。离大选只有五天了，林登·约翰逊上电视说，将全面停止轰炸。我们要停下来，因为和平解决战争的时机可能已经成熟。我将在一个星期内派遣一个美国代表团去巴黎进行和平谈判。你知道，一切都变了。
Is he going to intervene in the race? Is there going to be an October surprise that will change the whole narrative? And then on the 31st of October, Halloween, the bombshell comes Tom. So there's just five days to go till the election and LBJ goes on TV and he says, there's going to be a total bombing halt. We're stopping because a peaceful settlement to the war could be at hand. I'm going to send a US delegation to Paris for peace talks in a week's time. You know, everything has changed.
这是一个惊人的时刻，对吧？战争可能结束了，轰炸可能结束了，流血可能停止了。这会成为帮助汉弗莱扭转乾坤的事情吗？但接下来发生的事情成为了美国政治史上最大的阴谋论之一。简单说一下，尼克松无疑知道并且几周前就知道了林登·约翰逊一直在致力于一项和平协议。阴谋论是这样的。尼克松害怕
And this is an amazing moment, right? The war could be over, bombing could be over, the bloodshed. And is that going to be the thing that swings it for Humphrey? But it's what happens next that is one of American political history's great conspiracy theories. So just to lay it out, Nixon undoubtedly knew and had known for weeks that LBJ was working on a peace deal. The conspiracy theory. Nixon was frightened
这会让他输掉大选，于是他暗中破坏。他破坏的方式是通过一个名叫安娜·陈纳德（Anna Chennault）的女人，她被称为“龙夫人”。她出生在中国。她曾嫁给一位美国将军，后者在二战中指挥过一组战斗机飞行员，即中美混合团的飞行员。安娜·陈纳德是一位重要的社交名媛和共和党筹款人，在反共圈子里非常活跃，在东南亚有着大量人脉。阴谋论是这样流传的，尼克松让她联系南越
that this would cost him the election and he worked secretly to destroy it. And the way he destroyed it was by using a woman called Anna Chanalt who was nicknamed the Dragon Lady. So she was Chinese-born. She'd been married to an American general who had commanded a group of fighter pilots, Chinese and American fighter pilots in the Second World War. Anna Schenalt is a big society hostess and Republican fundraiser, very active in anti-communist circles, loads of contacts in Southeast Asia. And the conspiracy theory runs like this, that Nixon got her to contact South Vietnam's
总统阮文绍（Thieu）并告诉他，我会为你争取更好的协议。不要去巴黎参加和平谈判。按我说的做，你在我这里就会没事的。阮文绍照办了。他没有去巴黎。和平谈判破裂了。和平的机会消失了。是尼克松破坏了它，违反了1799年的《洛根法案》。不是1799年的《洛根法案》。不是《洛根法案》。《洛根法案》禁止私人公民与外国政府建立外交联系。所以这是叛国罪。林登·约翰逊知道这是叛国罪，但他没有公开，因为他没有
president Chiu and told him, I'll get you a better deal. Don't go to Paris for the peace talks. Do what I tell you and you'll be all right with me. Chu did as he was told. He didn't go to Paris. The peace talks fell apart. The peace chance was gone. It was Nixon who destroyed it, breaking the Logan Act of 1799. Not the Logan Act of 1799. Not the Logan Act. The Logan Act, which forbids private citizens from making diplomatic links with foreign governments. So it's treason. LBJ knew it was treason, but he didn't go public because he didn't have
确凿的证据，而且他不想玷污尼克松的登基总统之位。因此，尼克松侥幸逃脱了蓄意破坏和平协议的罪行，窃取了选举。成千上万的人不必要地死去了。尼克松竟然做出这种可怕的事，汤姆。这是真的吗？不，我认为这不是真的。好吧。我认为这不是真的。
concrete proof and he didn't want to taint Nixon's ascension to the presidency. And so Nixon got away with sabotaging the peace deal and stole the election. And thousands of people died unnecessarily. What a terrible thing for Nixon to have done, Tom. Is it true? No, I don't think it is true. Okay. I don't think it is true.
卢克·尼克特也不这样认为。没错。他也不这么认为。首先，尼克松的竞选团队与安娜·陈纳德有过接触，这是真的。毫无疑问。他与安娜·陈纳德有过接触。毫无疑问。他在柏林林的公寓里会见了她。他与南越大使一起会见了她。
And neither does Luke Nickter. Right. He doesn't either. First of all, it is true that Nixon's campaign was in touch with Anna Schenal. No doubt about that. He met was in touch with Anna Chanel. No doubt about that. He met her at his Park Lane apartment. He met her with the South Vietnamese ambassador.
不过她就是那种喜欢总统候选人的女人，不是吗？完全是的。她总是到处晃荡。她是个社交名媛。绝对的。她说尼克松向她保证，他会确保越南从他那里得到比在民主党人统治下更好的待遇。我想他可能确实向她保证过。
She's the kind of woman who loves a presidential candidate though, isn't she? Totally. She's always hanging. She's a society hostess. Exactly. She says that Nixon promised her that he would make sure Vietnam gets better treatment from me than under the Democrats. I think he probably did promise her that.
我坚信他向我也确实认为，他对她说，如果你能成为我和西贡之间的中间人，那就太棒了。因为我们知道这一点，因为哈尔德曼为此写了笔记。让陈纳德继续在SVN（南越）工作。我们也毫无疑问地知道，林登·约翰逊知道尼克松与这个安娜·陈纳德勾搭在一起，因为我们有他在11月1日与汉弗莱竞选团队的一位朋友交谈的记录。尼克松陷得很深，告诉阮文绍和所有人不要在任何事情上顺从我。阮文绍认为我们会出卖他，尼克松已经说服了他，还有这个该死的老太婆陈纳德太太，她也参与其中。
No doubt in my mind he promised to that. I also do think it's true that he said to her, it'd be brilliant if you could be a go between me and Saigon. Because we know that because Haldeman wrote notes about it. Keep Chanholt working on SVN South Vietnam. We also know, beyond doubt, that Lyndon Johnson knew that Nixon was in with this Anna Schenald because we have a record of him talking to a friend of his from the Humphrey campaign on the 1st of November. Nixon is in deep telling Chew and all of them not to go along with me on anything. Chew thinks that we will sell him out and Nixon has convinced him and this damn little old woman, Mrs. Schenald, she's been in on it.
这很符合林登·约翰逊的作风。但我认为，我认为这些警告无论如何都太夸张了。所以第一个警告是，尼克松与南越有接触是完全自然且合理的。自20世纪50年代以来，他曾多次访问西贡。他在那里已经有了人脉。考虑到他在民调中领先，他很快就要成为总统，而他的国家正卷入南越战争，他与南越领导层有接触并不奇怪。
That's very much OBJ. But I think that, I think the caveats, however, are too great. So the first caveat is Nixon having contacts with South Vietnam is completely natural and reasonable. He has been to Saigon multiple times since the 1950s. He already has contacts there. It's not weird that he has contacts with the South Vietnamese leadership, given that he's ahead in the polls. He's going to be president very shortly and his country is engaged in South Vietnam.
如果他没有以某种非正式的方式与南越保持联系，那才叫奇怪呢。你不觉得吗？我的意思是，他会与他们交谈这显然是不言而喻的，我猜。我认为他确实利用了陈纳德太太作为中间人，但我认为她没有所有人想象的那么重要。包括陈纳德太太自己？是的。她夸大了自己的角色。她喜欢认为自己极其重要，但我认为她没有所有人想象的那么重要。包括陈纳德太太自己？是的。她夸大了自己的角色。她喜欢认为自己极其重要，但我认为尼克松可能有很多中间人，她只是其中之一。最重要的是，阴谋论完全抓错了重点。
It would be bizarre if he wasn't in touch in some informal way with the South Vietnamese. Don't you think? I mean, it obviously stands to reason that he would be talking to them, I guess. I think he did use Mrs. Chanul as an intermediary, but I don't think she's as important as everybody thinks. Including Mrs. Chanul? Yeah. She bigs up her own role. She likes to think she's terribly important, but I don't think she's as important as everybody thinks. Including Mrs. Chanul. Yeah. She bigs up her own role. She likes to think she's terribly important, but I think Nixon probably has many intermediaries and she is merely one. And above all, the conspiracy theory completely misses the point.
南越人无论如何也永远、永远不会接受林登·约翰逊的协议。恰巧的是，我认为对此的最终定论是在仅仅几周前由历史学家大卫·L·普伦蒂斯（David L. Prentiss）发表在《外交史》杂志上的。他挖掘了其他历史学家忽视的南越资料。简而言之，他说，听着，阮文绍总统永远、永远不会顺从和平协议。他身边有一个越共代表参加和谈。这对他是绝对的红线。此外，阮文绍总统早就认为民主党人和汉弗莱是一群废物。他甚至不想轰炸北方。我想要一个
The South Vietnamese were never, ever, ever going to go for Lyndon Johnson's deal anyway. And as it happens, what I think is the last word on this was published only a couple of weeks ago in the journal Diplomatic History by a historian, David L. Prentiss. And he dug into the South Vietnamese sources that other historians have ignored. So to cut the long story short, he says, listen, President Chu was never ever going to go along with the peace deal. I had a Viet Cong round the table with him in peace talks. That was like an absolute red line for him. Also, President Chu already thought the Democrats in Humphrey is a waste of space. He doesn't even want to bond the North. I want someone
会轰炸北方的人。所以阮文绍总统早就认为尼克松会比他好得多。他不需要尼克松来告诉他。他不需要陈纳德太太带着口信出现。他永远不会去巴黎参加这些和平协议，而且他总是会破坏这个协议。但为什么林登·约翰逊不知道这一点呢？林登·约翰逊有点被他的首席谈判代表艾弗里·哈里曼（Averell Harriman）所迷惑，后者是一个狂热的民主党人，基本上说，我的首要任务实际上是让汉弗莱当选。所以我想他从自己的人那里得到了混乱的信号，林登·约翰逊。我认为林登·约翰逊也迷惑了自己，以为自己比实际情况拥有更多的代理权和控制权
who will bond the North. So President Chu already thought Nixon would be much better than him. He doesn't need Nixon to tell him. He doesn't need Mrs. Chanel to turn up with a message. He's never going to go to Paris for these peace talks and he's always going to sink the deal. But how come that LBJ didn't know that? LBJ was slightly being deluded, I think, by his chief negotiator, Avril Harriman, who was a very keen Democrat and basically said, my priority is actually to get Humphrey elected. So I think he's getting confusing signals from his own people, LBJ. I think LBJ has also deluded himself into thinking he has more agency and more
南越。而且我认为，你知道，美国人在这个问题上有很长的历史，总是对越南发生的事情产生幻觉，同时也剥夺了南越人的任何代理权。我认为这正是这个阴谋论所做的事情。它说和平失败完全是尼克松的责任。南越人永远不会签署这份和平协议。不要自欺欺人了。
control over the South Vietnamese than he does. And I think, you know, the Americans have a long history in this of deluding themselves about what's happening in Vietnam and also denying the South Vietnamese any agency Vietnamese any agency. And I think that's what this conspiracy theory does. It says it's all on Nixon that the peace failed. The South Vietnamese are never going to sign this peace. Don't delude yourselves.
人们是从什么时候开始谈论这个阴谋的？是水门事件之后吗？是的，大概在水门事件前后，我会这么说。所以是70年代。人们在70年代就开始谈论了。当然发生的情况是，人们已经准备好相信尼克松最坏的一面。民主党人喜欢找到一个借口来解释他们为什么失败，对吧？是的，那是因为我们被这个可怕的家伙欺骗了。我不怀疑尼克松在向南越发信号，但我认为它们完全无关紧要。我
When do people start talking about this conspiracy? Is it post Watergate? Yeah, round about Watergate, I would say. So 70s. People are talking about in 70s. And of course what happens is people are primed to believe the worst of Nixon. Democrats love the thought of having an excuse why they lost, right? Yeah, it's because we were cheated by this terrible man. I don't doubt that Nixon is sending signals to South Vietnam, but I think they're completely irrelevant. I don't
不认为这是他赢得大选的原因。无论如何，让我们谈谈选举之夜吧。那是1968年11月5日。尼克松在纽约华尔道夫酒店的35层。尼克松是个极好的顾家好男人，他为自己和帕特以及女儿们预订了不同的房间，他基本上不想和他们一起看。他对他们说，我害怕自己会再次输掉。他们说，我们承受不起失望。我觉得这很公平。他们要待在单独的房间里。所以他作为迪克·尼克松，其他任何总统
think they're why he wins the election at all. Anyway, let's get to election nightness. It's the 5th of November, 1968. Nixon's in the Waldorf Astoria, New York on the 35th floor. Nixon being the great family man that he is, he's booked separate rooms for himself and patterned his daughters and he basically doesn't want to watch it with them. He said to them, I'm frightened I'm going to lose again. And they said, we can't take the disappointment. I think that's fair enough. They're going to be off in a separate room. So he being Dick Nixon, every other presidential
候选人都和最亲密的朋友、助手坐在一起，吃着多力多滋薯片什么的。尼克松独自坐在黑暗中，手里拿着黄色记事本，给自己写着决心书。但这能让你为最坏的情况做好准备。确实如此。好吧，那是，那是他的心态。我想如果我站在他的鞋子里，我也会这么做。我才不要呢。我的意思是，你不会想成为希拉里·克林顿，你知道的，周围有巨大的派对气球什么的。我的意思是，那太糟糕了。当然。在国际电视上。而这正是大多数总统候选人所做的。他们把派对准备好了。尼克松是一个无论如何都讨厌派对的人。所以我的意思是，他绝对不会让我去参加派对。所以第一批选票结果开始出炉，关于华盛顿的故事。我们在华盛顿那一集里已经总结过了，但提醒大家一下，他只赢了五个州和一000万选票。他的支持率
candidate sits with their closest friends, their aides, got like Doritos or whatever. Nixon sits on his own in the dark with his yellow pad writing resolutions to himself. But it prepares you for the worst. It does. Well, that's, that's his mentality. I think that's what I'd do in his shoes. I wouldn't want it. I mean, you wouldn't want to be Hillary Clinton, you know, with a massive great party balloons and everything. I mean, that would be terrible. Of course. On international television. And that's what most presidential candidates do. They have the party ready. Nixon is a man who hates parties anyway. So I mean, he's never going to get me into a party. So the first returns start to come in Wallace, the Wallace story. We kind of wrap that up in the Wallace episode, but just to remind people, he only won five states and 10 million votes. His support has
被汉弗莱和尼克松两面夹击。所以实际上尼克松将在田纳西州、卡罗莱纳州、佛罗里达州和弗吉尼亚州这些南方外围州击退华盛顿。然而，对尼克松来说是个坏消息，汉弗莱也蚕食了华盛顿在北方的支持。基本上，蓝领工会成员正在回家，其中一些人是最后一次回到民主党。他们在密歇根州和铁锈带等地方给民主党最后一次机会。所以选局非常非常接近。
been squeezed by both Humphrey and Nixon. So actually Nixon is going to fight off Wallace in Tennessee and the Carolinas and Florida and Virginia in the sort of outer Southern states. However, bad news for Nixon, Humphrey has also eaten into Wallace's support in the North. Basically, the blue collar union members are coming home, some of them for the very last time, to the Democrats. They're giving the Democrats one last chance in your Michigan's and your kind of Rust Belt states and so on. So it's very, very close.
到了午夜。汉弗莱在普选票上实际上稍微领先，结果将取决于1960年尼克松失败时决定胜负的那四个州：加利福尼亚州、俄亥俄州、伊利诺伊州和德克萨斯州。令人难以置信的紧张。巨大的戏剧性，汤姆。是的。帕特·尼克松在浴室里呕吐，因为她太紧张了。字面意义上的呕吐。字面意义上的呕吐。
You get to midnight. Humphrey is actually just ahead in the popular vote and it's going to come down to the same four states that decided it in 1960 when Nixon lost us. California, Ohio, Illinois and Texas. Unbelievable tension. Great drama, Tom. Yeah. Pat Nixon is in the bathroom being sick because she's so nervous. Literally sick. Literally sick.
哇。到了清晨，尼克松和汉弗莱现在不相上下。他们的得票率都是43%。德克萨斯州归了汉弗莱。宾夕法尼亚州归了汉弗莱。纽约州归了汉弗莱。但尼克松在加利福尼亚州、俄亥俄州、伊利诺伊州领先。终于，来自芝加哥的消息，理查德·J·戴利市长。
Wow. By the early hours of the morning, Nixon and Humphrey are now neck and neck. They're at 43% each. Texas goes for Humphrey. Pennsylvania goes for Humphrey. New York goes for Humphrey. But Nixon is ahead in California, in Ohio, in Illinois. And at last, the news from Chicago, Mayor Daley.
哇，他又出现了。戴利市长一直扣着这些票箱不放，不公布结果。因为大概他想让民主党赢。是的，他确实想。我想他确实想让民主党赢。戴利市长在玩弄选票箱安全方面可能稍微有点黑历史。最后他公布了芝加哥的结果，这让尼克松在伊利诺伊州反超，并将总统宝座拱手相让。
Wow, he pops up again. Mayor Daley has been sitting on these boxes, not releasing the results. Because presumably he wants the Democrats to win. He does, yeah. I think he does want the Democrats to win. Mayor Daley has a slight history perhaps of playing fast and loose with ballot box security. And finally he releases the results from Chicago and they send Nixon over the top in Illinois and they give him the presidency.
所以在投出的7000多万张选票中，他仅仅赢了五十万票，优势是五十万张选票，他做到了。他驱散了所有失败的记忆，上演了美国历史上最伟大的东山再起之一。是的。所以美国政治生活中还有第二幕。完全正确。他在清晨八点左右走进大厅，一杯牛奶
So out of more than 70 million votes cast, he wins by just half a million, the margin is half a million votes and he's done it. He has banished the memories of all his defeats and he has pulled off one of American history's great comebacks. Yeah. So there is a second act in American political life. Exactly. He goes down the hall at eight o'clock in the morning or so, glass of milk
去告诉他的家人，这是他们第一次听到这个消息，因为他们一直被关在房间里。在浴室里呕吐。帕特简直不敢相信。她说，哦，迪克，我们确定伊利诺伊州稳了吗？他说，我们确信，帕特。接着她放声大哭。然后他下楼去迎接媒体。那是华尔道夫酒店的正午。我们总是喜欢一点感人的尼克松修辞。我们喜欢来点甜言蜜语，不是吗？我们喜欢来点甜言蜜语。所以他是这么说的，
to tell his family this is the first they've heard of it because they've been locked up in their room. Vomiting in the bathroom. Hatt can't believe it. She says, oh, Dick, are we sure of Illinois? And he says, we are sure of Pat. And she bursts into floods of tears. And then he comes downstairs to greet the media. It's midday in the Waldorf Astoria. And we always like a bit of moving Nixon rhetoric. We like some syrup, don't we? We like a bit of syrup. So this is what he says,
把这件事告诉家人，因为这是他们第一次听到，他们一直被关在房间里。在浴室里呕吐。哈特简直不敢相信。她说，哦，迪克，我们对伊利诺伊州有把握吗？他说，我们对帕特有把握。然后她放声大哭。接着他下楼去迎接媒体。华尔道夫酒店正值正午。我们总是喜欢听一点感人的尼克松式雄辩。我们喜欢煽情的话，不是吗？我们喜欢一点煽情。所以他是这样说的：
I saw many signs in this campaign. I don't want to degenerate into the Somerset voice again. Some of them were not friendly and some of them were very friendly. But the one that touched me the most was the one I saw in Deshla, Ohio at the end of a long day of whistle stopping. A little town, I suppose. Five times the population was there in the dusk, almost impossible to see, but a teenager held up a sign, bring us together. So that definitely happened. And that will be the great objective of this
我在这次竞选活动中看到了许多标语。我不想再次陷入萨默塞特口音。有些标语并不友好，有些则非常友好。但最触动我的是我在俄亥俄州德什拉看到的那个，那是在漫长的一天频繁拉票的结束时。一个不错的小镇，我想。傍晚时分，人口的五倍聚集在那里，几乎看不清，但一个青少年举着一个标语：把我们团结在一起。所以这确实发生了。这将是这个……的宏伟目标
administration. We want to bridge the generation gap. We want to bridge the gap between the races. We want to bring America together. And so Tom, the Nixon golden age begins. Because spoiler alert, bringing America together is exactly what Nixon succeeds in doing. All Americans united in the conviction that he should resign after Watergate. That's not even true. That's not even true. No. People were still reaching for him after Watergate.
政府。我们想要弥合代沟。我们想要弥合种族之间的鸿沟。我们想要把美国团结在一起。所以，汤姆，尼克松黄金时代开始了。因为剧透一下，把美国团结在一起正是尼克松成功做到的事。所有美国人都坚信他在水门事件后应该辞职。这甚至都不是真的。这甚至都不是真的。不。水门事件后，人们仍然在支持他。
Yeah, there's still people who said, come on, I think Nixon's got a very bad press. We all, you know, do the odd thing we don't, you know, we're not too proud of. Okay. So yeah, Tom, that's the, um, so that's it. I just mentioned Watergate because you've heard six episodes on America in 1968, but if you simply can't bear, you know, drawing a line down to this, if you'd like to hear more Nixon, you can go and listen to the two episodes that we recorded over about 73 years ago on Watergate.
是的，仍然有人说，得了吧，我认为尼克松受到了非常糟糕的媒体评价。你知道，我们大家都会做一些我们自己不太引以为傲的怪事。好吧。所以，是的，汤姆，那就是……嗯，就是这样。我提到水门事件是因为你们已经听了六集关于1968年美国的节目，但如果你实在无法忍受划清界限，如果你想听更多关于尼克松的内容，你可以去听听我们大约73年前录制的关于水门事件的两集节目。
Dominic again at his absolute best as he has been in this series. So thank you very much Dominic for all of that, your unparalleled expertise and thank you everyone who has listened. Maybe Tom, I think we should have Dick Nixon himself to play us out. Bye bye. Bye bye. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
多米尼克再次展现了他最好的状态，就像他在这个系列中一直做的那样。非常感谢多米尼克带给我们这一切，你无与伦比的专业知识，也谢谢每一位收听的听众。也许，汤姆，我想我们应该让理查德·尼克松本人来为我们演奏结束曲。再见。再见。本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。